ladies and gentlemen we have
long held conversations here in the tim
cast irl podcast about
wokeness critical theory critical race
theory gender ideology
and its negative impacts for the most
part on
our society it is the one of the
principal factors in the culture war
which is
tearing the united states apart in my
opinion and now france
has basically come out saying it we've
got emmanuel macron president of france
basically saying that these ideas are
dangerous but now
intellectuals and politicians in french
are france are basically saying
the idea of the ideology coming out of
american universities this this critical
theory this far left wokeness
is destroying french identity and
destroying the country
and this is coming from people viewed as
being
on the left and i gotta say they're not
wrong
we're looking at the big story of the
day
impeachment which is completely
meaningless
but it's tribalism this tribalism is a
key element of what's
splitting apart not just the united
states but other countries impeachment
is meaningless
we know it's not going to happen we know
that 47 republicans already said
no yes they're going to be moving
forward but it seems to be a big waste
of time to try and impeach a president
who's
a former president he's not even office
anymore so we're not even going to get
into it it just seems like
there's no reason to the bigger issue in
my in my opinion is the root cause of
all this
and as everybody basically knows well
not everybody but
politics is downstream from culture what
starts in the cultural arena eventually
moves
into the political spaces so now we're
finally seeing some people in government
notably in france waking up to the
problems being caused by this critical
theory
unfortunately we had trump who didn't
necessarily realize it but at least took
action against it
now france is kind of waking up to this
and there are a few other stories in the
periphery of this we have this
this ridiculous story of this i think
it's an la times columnist
complaining that her trump supporting
neighbors who
politely shoveled her driveway were like
nazis and what should she do oh no this
huge
problem we have some random dude and
this one really triggered luke
going on twitter and claiming that
cracker barrel was racist
and making up some insane story
this is so ridiculous this this this
whatever is going on
in this far left woken stuff that we've
long talked about we can see it's just
it's still happening it's getting worse
maybe with france stepping up and
actually saying something about it
maybe maybe there can be some changes
made i gotta admit i'm not entirely
confident so we'll get we'll get into
all this we'll talk about some of the
other news that's going on today
we are being joined today by in in this
space especially one of the most
important individuals
we have siraj hashmi who's a journalist
with the washington examiner
but suraj has the list it is a list of
people who should have their phones
taken away for what bad tweets right
usually bad cringe-worthy yeah
i i try to keep the food takes out of it
because there are a lot of bad food
takes out
takes two but mostly bad tweets and
cringe-worthy tweets for sure
so and this is cross-spectrum it doesn't
matter if you're left or right if you
have a dumb tweet you get put on the
list yeah
you know it it actually i did it all on
super bowl sunday i released an
all decade list so from 2011 to 2020 i
kept it at 10
because if i did more than 10 i killed
myself but
i found that the number one person above
all everyone else
was anthony weiner deserving to have his
phone taken the most because if you
remember
in may 2011. he sent the picture
of his junk to one of his followers
resulting in him
resigning from congress a minor yeah and
then and then
and then yeah that was later that was
2016.
more than once that yeah so it was later
uh his name is wienerton
so yeah obviously it's so on the nose uh
and what makes it worse obviously is
that when he was
found to have been sexting a miner a
15-year-old girl
they opened up a criminal investigation
on him that's when the fbi
seized his laptop that's when on the
laptop
they found hillary clinton's emails and
that's when 11 days prior to the 2016
presidential election james comey sent
a letter to the senate judiciary
committee saying he's representing the
investigation
11 days before the presidential election
2016 as we all know
what happened and i'm not going to say
that that alone is why hillary clinton
lost
butterflies but it didn't help her
and so he was number one number two i
put world health organization good
good uh just for the tweet last year
about saying that uh coped was not
uh contracted from human human or it
could be transmitted air transmission
yeah
um and then third and i'll just cap that
three was
former pittsburgh steelers running back
richard mendenhall
who after the navy seal team 6 raid
that killed osama bin laden basically
tweeted out
how how could so many people be
celebrating
one man's death like there's got to be
another side to this story
yeah conspiracy theories yeah amazing
amazing amazing
and uh you mentioned too that uh you've
had trump on the list at some point
uh i had him on the list a lot i would
say the
person i've had on the list the most
though is washington post blogger
jennifer rubin
uh yeah yeah i was gonna say about trump
though they took his phone away
they did they did so you know once once
they actually suspend the twitter
account they retire from the list
because
the list works he's free yeah all right
cool man we'll get into this stuff we
also got luke he's hanging out you know
i'm making my own list
tim right now as we're speaking yeah i
heard congress
is impeaching presidents for uh
violating the constitution
i have a long list of presidents that i
want to give to congress
what's the same way about that well well
hold on in terms of i saw one person
tweet we should remove
these people who violated their oath the
constitution uh we should remove people
who voted
to uh support trump's objection by remo
you know
let me clarify they said the people who
voted to support donald trump and his
objection
to steal the election violated their
oath the constitution and should be
expelled and i was like okay i think we
have a list of what like 430 names
that fall into the violating the earth
of the constitution so i'm game if
they're like we're going to expel for
this reason let's let's
let's roll i got a big list i'm
optimistic a lot of presidents violated
the constitution but anyway
today i also launched a t-shirt that i'm
very excited about it's of bill hicks so
ever i have to say this stop saying it's
the alex jones t-shirt
it's not it's it's the bill hicks
t-shirt and you can get that shirt and
the shirt that i'm wearing right now on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com and because
you do i'm here and thank you very much
for having me
we got ian chilling what up everybody
i'm just going to give a little little
pre warning this isn't my wheelhouse
this episode so i'm going to try to keep
my
um yesterday you were on a roll i was on
fire
bring up fusion and i'm all in
electromagnetic vibrations i'm gonna try
to smooth this one through
although i thought it was interesting
what you were saying about the french
kind of calling out this
this wokeness because americans have
this this
you know this tendency towards
puritanism we always have and it's
almost like this is like modern-day
puritanism don't say those mean words
about me uh
and the french were like the reason we
were able to win the revolution it's
this like
european liberalism like real liberalism
they were literally the jacobins
yeah it was yaos right before before the
french revolution
the revolutionaries took hold but it was
yeah so if anybody is louis
he bankrupted the country of france to
basically to fund the americans to beat
the british
right well then well we also got
sarpatulids pressing all the buttons
i am over here in the corner and i am
also intrigued by france's role in this
because a lot of these bad ideas from my
understanding
came from there yes and we're gonna get
into these stories before we do head
over to timcast.com become a member
we have set up this website with members
only content we are expanding the site
expect there to be way more stuff we're
gonna do guest blogs from other people
we're gonna start a vlog
we're gonna actually launch more
websites but for the time being we've
set this up you can become a member and
get access to access to exclusive
segments
and episodes only available to our
members and this is basically because
the purge is real
they've been banning a lot of people
they've recently been they've been
banning progressives so now it's coming
from the left
we'll see how things go but they may at
some point come and ban this channel
because look
we're fairly anti-establishment they
can't have that they'd much prefer us to
be falling in line with jimmy kimmel or
whatever we don't do that so in the
event we do get banned you can find us
at timcast.com and
your membership helps support the show
and make sure that we can keep
growing and functioning bring on more
people do more content so it is greatly
appreciated don't forget to like share
subscribe
share the podcast with your friends if
you really do like it let's check out
this story this is
amazingly from the new york times will
american ideas tear france apart
some of its leaders think so politicians
and prominent intellectuals say
social theories from the us on race
gender and post-colonialism
are a threat to french identity and the
french republic now that is
amazing they say high-profile
intellectuals and journalists are
warning
that progressive american ideas
specifically on race
gender post-colonialism are undermining
their society there's a battle to wage
against an intellectual matrix from
american universities warn mr macron's
education minister
emboldened by these comments prominent
intellectuals have banded together
against what they regard as
contamination by the out-of-control
woke leftism of american campuses
and attended cancel culture of all of
the countries in europe
that we would point to france is
particularly left not the like everyone
likes to point to scandinavia but come
on
the french revolution the leftists the
socialists the jacobins
i'm not saying that they're the furthest
left but you know they're one of the
examples people cite
especially considering jacobid magazine
is a socialist magazine
and they're stepping up and saying nah
to all this stuff
which is good because in my opinion the
wokeness on the left
is infecting left ideas and turning it
into a weird dogmatic cult ideology that
makes no sense
and i saw the best tweet to explain it
you guys
i want to hear your thoughts on this i
saw a really wonderful tweet breaking
down
like gender ideology they said sexism
is when you say when someone says that
women should be
you know they believe doing the dishes
you know not men
feminism is when the woman comes out and
says both men and women
can be doing the dishes and gender
ideology says
anybody who does the dishes is a woman
you get it
like that's that's pretty like i saw
that and i was like that's that's
actually a good example
of like what's happening because you
look at
actual traditional feminism and it's
like women and men can wear whatever
they want
now in the modern era of this critical
theory it's whoever wears feminine
clothes
is a woman and whoever wears masculine
clothes a man which is not
doesn't make a whole lot of sense you
know what i mean yeah uh
it's actually kind of interesting and
just because i'm a practicing muslim in
this kind of this
story in france it impacts me in a way
because of obviously the the the
struggles that the french
people have had with sort of this rising
threat of islamic terrorism
in the last decade um but
with respect to your point about you
know whoever wears women's clothes
and men's clothes like i've read
obviously in like religious
in islamic scripture that like a sign of
the end of times
is like when you cannot tell the
difference between men and women is that
really in there
yeah it's it's kind of scary in a way uh
again this is like
this is religious stuff if you are if
you are subscribed to the islamic faith
that you probably know what i'm talking
about
but you know religion obviously isn't
for everyone uh
and it's all based on faith um i mean i
do believe
in a god i do believe that
there is a life after this one but i am
not going to be dogmatic and just preach
to you what
is right and what is wrong but with
respect to this uh
st about this sort of you mentioned the
word contagion
that is obviously very fascinating
because for the longest time at least
for the last like century
uh the red scare has been considered
long held in europe as
like an international contagion this
threat of communism
that is going to jump from one country
to the next
and for it to kind of be turned on its
head and
say that that's coming from the united
states based on
how woke everyone has become it's
pretty stunning really yeah the daily
mail had an interesting blurb about this
that i think describes
everything that we're talking about and
they said quote they are arguing that
american ideas on race gender
post-colonialism
especially those coming from u.s
universities are undermining
french society and are an attack on
french
heritage i mean that's a pretty bold
statement and of course a lot of people
would agree but a lot of people are even
scared
to agree to that because of our current
political climate and to have
france of all countries call it out is
extremely interesting
especially with individuals like
emmanuel macron a former rothschild
banker who was deemed
the savior of europe he was deemed as
this superstar the mainstream media
loved him
we were there were you there with me
when we were there for emmanuel macron's
uh
kind of celebration when he won the
streets were jam-packed
everywhere everyone loved him then he
came in and then he started
doing austerity measures and then he
started cutting social services are you
sure
and then it was people were freaked out
and that i covered so many riots in
france
if anyone knows how to protest it is the
french people they got crazy they got
intense and we have seen levels of
violence with the yellow vests
that we haven't seen before in in
decades
with the civil war and rest unfolded
because of emmanuel macron so to see him
now
say these kind of things that that are
against the establishment is interesting
but also according to the new york times
he's only doing this
because he's trying to court the right
during the next election
but that's the new york times what the
new york times says is
is only weirdly left-wing
it's not economic well it's promoted by
the establishment right promoted by the
mainstream media the same mainstream
media that kind of both
boasted him up and made him as popular
as he is that's that's that's the
contradicting point here that i wanted
to point out
there are a lot of leftists who are
anti-woke there's just not enough
willing to speak out and call it out
but there was a shout out to rania kalik
who's an anti-war progressive
who wrote about or made it she made a
video it was really funny probably
really offensive these people called
woke washing
where it's like you get the military
industrial complex and it's like good
news everybody the ceos of all the
biggest defense contractors are women
we've won it's like no they're blowing
up kids it's okay
it is a woman of color doing it like if
that is the you know
the measure of success we got serious
problems
i was gonna say luke uh it
with people celebrating in the streets
when macron won and it suddenly
dawned on me that the 2017 french
election
has so many parallels to the 2020
election just because
the candidates involved i mean are you
sure yeah i was just going to ask him
like were people celebrating the streets
because it was marine le pen who wasn't
elected
because that's what it sounds like and
you get someone who's kind of as milk
toast as
you know between biden and macron yeah
and i think
i think that a lot of people were like
yeah i expected biden to suck i didn't
expect him to buy
i i did not expect biden to be this
terrible this quickly
well if you look at the way he was
highlighted i mean there was a lot of
controversies surrounding his banker
past
and that was kind of shrugged underneath
the rug and when you were really seeing
him he was seen as an all-star he was
literally praised
as the man who's going to save europe
and people were so angry at him and so
disappointed
there was literal chemical agents and
evacuation plans
made for the paris capital for
government officials because of how
serious the protests got
i can't tell you the level of intensity
i mean i
don't even you know for i got ptsd from
what i saw
at the paris protests and i don't even
want to talk about all the gory details
but
some of the most intense street fighting
i have ever seen in my life happened
because of this outrage against macron
a lot of people are angry with him so
this could be a larger political ploy i
hope not i don't trust macron
but he does bring up good points here
let's be real macron is saying this
people on the left don't view mccrone as
left-wing you know he's
he's a bankster he's a he's far right
he's a nationalist all of those things
so they viewed you know him it's you
know i guess what the problem is left
it's similar here with joe biden they're
like oh joe biden's bad but
trump is worse they're like joe budden's
actually a republican but trump is a
fascist and it's like
okay but you know they view macron
similarly marine le pen was a fascist
and
you know emmanuel macron is just far
right so they're like it's better i
guess but they'll still protest it
yeah i don't know how they i mean i know
the french elections are like
almost like a jungle primary like in
california they basically get the top
two vote together and then they
you know have that runoff i that's the
thing is like the
the overton window in just the global
political
spectrum has shifted so far to the left
yet everybody keeps
backlashing against it and voting people
who are just so far to the right of that
i mean i mean joe biden i've you know
from like the charlie kirks of the world
the trump campaign
saying that like joe biden is actually a
trojan horse
horse for socialism the guy has always
been the corporatist like he's only put
big wall street k street people into
his administration to be fair that is
corporate socialism at the very least
you know the big companies get their
bailouts they get their money printed
for them and then everyone else gets the
crumbs
i'm look when i hear the left complain
about that stuff i'm like you're correct
i agree i think social
social socialism is bad you're mad
they're giving to the corporations i'm
mad about it in general but also that
they're giving to the corporations
and i don't want socialism but i think
we can agree when they they print money
and just give it to
you know transfer the wealth from the
people to the top you know political
elites and establishment elites
that's messed up yeah i mean just look
at these ppp loans uh
you know i love tom brady i grew up in
new england i'm a huge new england
patriots fan
and tom brady is a god amongst men why
the hell
is he his company tb12 getting pvp loans
i mean crazy i mean i'm fine with
companies getting access to money to pay
their employees
just because a company's big doesn't
mean that they probably they probably
still have employees to pay
the problem is that people can't spend
money outside of for the most part big
box stores and amazon
right and so that's funneling all of the
stimulus and ppp money
back into the hands of major
corporations where they can then
stockpile it if you think that's the
problem wait until you find out about
the military industrial complex
and corporate welfare that i will tell
you i will tell you this
the one the reason why i however became
involved
not involved but ever got engaged in
politics was because
of the military-industrial complex
particularly the invasion of the iraq
war
i got i got to tell this story the iraq
war i got to tell this funny joke i just
heard
luke you have to ask me a question you
have to ask me what's the most common
french phrase
what's the most common french phrase i
give up
that's it get it it's funny right
are we allowed to make jokes like that
on youtube i would be
[Laughter]
they get into a vehicle with like some
russian guys and he's complaining about
the french and he looks over to his
friends and he's like hey what's the
most common french phrase and he leans
over i give up and they all start
laughing
uh french surrender jokes never get old
right but to add to the point that you
were saying uh
you made a very good point especially
with this wolk culture because you know
the guy who created mass incarceration
and a cop don't really say you're woke
don't really kind of support you know
they say they support black lives matter
but that's what happens culturally
it's used to divide and conquer us and
then the big institutional powers
push in their kind of puppet
establishment candidates they come in
and then they roll just like they ruled
before
with people thinking that something's
going to change when it's joked joe
biden is literally the institutional
racism they complain about
i mean black lives matter endorses the
guy
and then you know 40 days after he gets
elected or not
after he gets elected they're like we
still haven't heard from nobody i'm just
amazed that like joe biden
co-sponsored the 1994 crime bill
and hillary clinton gets more flak for
it for saying the word super predator
yeah to this day i just don't understand
it because joe biden
is like fumbly bumbly joe you know no i
mean i get it like
the maybe my favorite ever joe biden
moment was when he was vice president
and the onion ran the diamond joe biden
series on him just made him look like he
was
a loose cannon this is the big effing
deal
all that all that stuff it was funny i
feel like
people just like to gloss over that
stuff but you also luke you
you bring up a interesting point about
so like whole the
the adoption of black lives matter um
it's just amazing how so many of these
global corporations and their global
corporations no longer it's no longer
such a thing as
corporate america because these
countries have basically flooded the
flood the united states
and they go to countries like china they
go to southeast asia
for basically tax shelters when
it comes to things like black lives
matter
and racial equity or what have you
they rather flock to the chinese
communist party
and get that sweet sweet revenue yeah
like through nike through disney
say that they support like equal justice
for all
and then on the other side of the the
pacific you have the chinese communist
party
locking up a million plus uyghur muslims
just for the crime of practicing their
faith that's true but
uh you know shout out to disney for
giving a thank you to the paramilitary
group that's actually enforcing that
because they helped make mulan
yeah yeah there you go it's at that i
mean like talk about welcome
yeah talk about i know uh biden
appointed you know the former disney
representative to be the envoy to china
very fitting so uh everything works
great i love being lectured you know by
all these politicians
corporations the entertainment industry
silicon valley about racism and
injustice when
when it comes to china they're
absolutely silent about it they won't
dare talk about the actual racism and
injustices that happen there
since of course they're you know they
get money from them and that's crazy
well i got to ask you know
what is it that creates this kind of
person
who lines up in lockstep with massive
multinational corporations
the most notorious human rights abusers
to claim they have moral authority over
anybody
it's like the people standing next to
mcdonald's and starbucks and nike are
like
we're morally just and you're the bad
guys you know what it is
it is i mean all politics
is local when you don't have sort of a
add the human element of say for example
say if there were 1 million americans
who are locked up in the chinese
and in these re-education camps then
americans might actually care about it
but until that
until that happens these are foreign
distant people we've never heard of them
before
and therefore yeah i would have agreed
with you maybe four or five years ago
but now you've got articles in the
nation where they're like i'm for prison
abolition but i want all of these trump
insurrectionists right up yeah if they
came out and they were like
china has detained one million trump
supporters people in this country would
be like it's it's tough but you know
this this real threat is important that
these people are are seeking help
i mean they're literally calling for
truth and reconciliation commissions
they've legit been doing it for some
time now and it's only a matter of time
i mean they're gonna start firing people
yeah they're they're slowly like there's
this creep going on
where one day they'll say it's really
bad that you know
this racist person did this thing two
days later they'll say
this it's the most dangerous thing we've
ever seen in our lives then
a week later they'll say we're literally
facing extinction because of what this
man did like every day
whatever this one thing was they
exaggerated
and they and they so i'll give you an
example the january 6th incident right
the storming of the capital it was
definitely bad you know these people
stormed in
but what they keep they they've like
completely forgotten or purposefully
flubbed over what what really happened
some people stormed the front fighting
with cops pepper spraying them hitting
them all that bad stuff
and a lot of people walked leisurely
through the doors that were opened by
police
and took selfies with police officers so
that's all forgotten and now all that
anyone remembers of that
day is like a horde of violent
insurrectionists with a plan there was
no plan
people have no idea what they were doing
now they're trying to impeach a
president over it yeah but
my favorite thing is is how aoc turns
that day into she like she fabricates
this story and i mean it she literally
fabricated a story because all that
people remember about the six was the
storming of the capital they ignored the
entire morning of and what happened
so now aoc can claim in the early
afternoon something happened that made
no sense it's like
we forget essentially what happened on
the day and they gaslight us over and
over again
to make it seem worse than it really is
that's like leading to this dramatic
escalation where
we could get to a point we're at a point
where they're basically like we should
bring the domestic war
the war on terror home domestically to
go after the trump supporting extremists
there's like um a lack a lack of
critical thinking
or like a short-sightedness i'm not sure
exactly how to phrase it that i think a
lot of people suffer from
i don't really surround myself with
those people i'm used to hanging out
with like people that actually like
think about the past and like
equate that with what's going on and
like make think about it so but i think
a lot of people just are kind of driven
by like
like a lack of memory maybe they don't
have as good of a memory or something
lemmings
well i mean there are actual scientific
studies that
your memory tends to worsen during a
traumatic event
um or at least the correlation between
your memory not being as good that's why
you know when it's so important during
criminal prosecutions and trials that
you have multiple accounts you can
use forensic evidence to to try to prove
a particular
suspect or defendant committed a
particular crime because people's
memories are very
uh unreliable now um and
i mean we were talking obviously before
the show about aoc's timeline
you know it's so difficult for people to
sort of i'd say the biggest folly of all
of that
is that they a lot of journalists were
covering that
did not take a step back to actually
fact check exactly what was going on
their knees
just took it not even conservatives yeah
it took i took so we'll give everyone
the context aoc tells this story and
we've talked about it quite a bit
about you know being in the capital and
fearing for her life think she was gonna
die because a cop was knocking on the
door and she didn't know as a cop
so everyone just kind of took it to face
value and then michael tracy a
journalist made a comment that she was
manipulative
and that became the news cycle a day
later someone went hey wait a minute she
wasn't even in the capitol building
the story she was telling when she was
in her office and everyone went whoa she
wasn't even at the riot
and then i saw everyone you know even
ben shapiro
were pointing this out saying you know
maybe she was scared but she wasn't even
in the capital
and so i did this tweet and i had a
journalist from huffington post hit me
up saying my timeline was wrong
i was basically saying she was
exaggerating the story because the
evacuation she referenced everybody was
leisurely strolling through the building
like nothing was happening
so her claiming she was fearing for her
life when everyone was fine well i
deleted my tweet
because he told me that i was wrong and
i believed him turns out
he was wrong everybody was wrong aoc's
story about being pinned down in her
in her in a room with someone banging
the door happened a full
hour and 10 minutes before anyone
stormed any building
before the capital was breached so what
happens is
now that it's been a month and most
people have forgotten the timeline of
that day
and they only remember the snippet of
people stormed the capital it was scary
when aoc comes out and says someone
banged on my door it was scary
they instantly just mash that day into
one moment ignoring the timeline of
events
and then you realize aoc fabricated that
story
there's literally no way she thought
quote they got
in when no one had any idea that was
going to happen
i was watching the twitter feeds i was
watching the live streams i was watching
trump's speech
and at 1 pm i uploaded a video where i
said it's over everyone's going to leave
that's it it's boring nothing's going to
happen literally the exact same time she
thought the world was ending
i was saying it's nothing's happening
it's over and then an hour and 10
minutes later they breached the building
so she makes this stuff up what's even
worse is how you get even the fact
checkers like from snopes
uh then using their gravitas and
authority to
basically in a february third article
uh titled did aoc exaggerate the danger
she was in during the capital riot they
rank it mostly false
and then they say what's true
ocasio-cortez wasn't in the main capitol
building where the house and senate
chambers are located
but think about that they try to argue
yes they're like she wasn't in the
building yeah but the people were
storming it and she was scared and i'm
like
no that was hour it was over an hour
later
and they didn't evacuate the house
chamber until 2
39 so what a full hour and
what is this it was an hour and 40
minutes later they finally evacuated and
they're claiming she didn't exaggerate
well they didn't i mean they did say
here's this is why they said what's
false however
ocasio-cortez never claimed to be in the
main capitol building when the attack
on the capital began ocasio-cortez was
as she stated in her congressional
office which is located in the network
of offices and that's not true she
wasn't in her office at the time
she was evacuated at one o'clock before
the storm before this yeah
what does it say specifically yeah which
is located in the network
when when the riot happened is that what
it says what is the exact quote
when the attack began on the cap okay
right and so you could argue that the
breaching of the barricade was an attack
they'll get semantic on you right
they'll move the goal post
but but aoc was evacuated they did give
the all clear at 153 so maybe she went
back to her office
which would be very strange for her
story i was terrified they were to kill
me so i went back to my office as the
riot was happening
and that's why they came kicking her
door down looking for her basically they
didn't go to her they never went to her
building they're like opening up where
is she
that was a cop yeah at one o'clock she
didn't report to where she was supposed
to be
no did you ever figure out why yes a cop
was going and telling everybody they
were clearing the building because of a
bomb scare
okay that was according to huffington
post reporter that because there was a
bomb planted at the rnc which is just
right outside longworth
yeah in canon so what made her think
someone knocking on her door was
they got in and this was the end of her
life she had no idea
yeah but that's deep paranoia or she's
just lying
and also she said in her video that she
thought the capitol police officer
was possibly in on the riot again
how could she possibly have known that
without having seen any of the footage
of say like
any of the capital police officers like
taking selfies with
uh some of the other protesters yeah
that happened how would she know that
that this almost seems like a a memory
that she formed herself
making it or like kicks the door and she
has that much fear
when he came in yeah she when he was
allowed to end and he had she had so
much fear and distrust
of someone in uniform no that makes me
nervous or was he playing clothes
she didn't know who was knocking at the
door he was in a uniform someone knocked
on the door and she ran and hid in the
bathroom and the guy let her in
and then she looked at him in the eyes
she said that he looked like he wanted
to kill her he wanted
to hurt her she's like i don't know if
i'm projecting he knocked on the door
that amount of fear and paranoia that
she was exuding is dangerous for someone
in congress
to have right you're right but he
knocked on the door and then this person
said go
run hide why her assistant told her to
run and hide because someone knocked
down their door
i don't know these people are nuts man
but let's let's move forward i want to
keep on the critical race theory stuff
because we have the story from the new
york post
la times columnist blasted for comparing
trump-supporting neighbors
to nazi sympathizers this is the level
of depravity that we're starting to see
you know we were just mentioning in the
previous segment that
you could probably take a million trump
supporters put them in one of these
reeducation camps
and the left would be like good it's a
good thing
here's the story they say la times
columnist of virginia hefferman
heffernan is being slammed for a piece
in which she compared the trumpets next
door to our pandemic getaway
in upstate new york despite their
aggressive niceness
to nazi sympathizers and hezbollah
because they backed donald
trump the brooklyn-born writer also a
cultural columnist at wired
wrote on friday that her neighbors who
seem as devoted to the ex-president as
you can get without being q
fans just plowed our driveway without
being asked and did a great job
how am i going to resist demands for
unity in the face of this act of
aggressiveness this is this an onion
article
no that's really nice it's la times
literally a journalist posting her l
yeah
do they think this resonates with people
you know
so her friendly neighbors scooped her
driveway cleaned the snow off
it was it was pretty deep too like the
picture was nuts like
it was like a huge like there was a lot
of snow up against her building they did
a lot of work
and she's like how am i supposed to not
unify with them now
oh no the propagandists on twitter are
telling you to hate your neighbor and
it's so hard because they're good people
what's so wild about it is that in 2016
everyone was blaming trump's victory
on how all of his supporters are so
insulated and they would not engage with
other people
with from other communities and then
here you go
a neighbor trying to plow someone else's
driveway showing like an act of
friendship and trying to reach out and
all of a sudden
can't do it can't can't you're a
hesitant and a nazi
i mean this is cult-like behavior it's
sad i feel sorry for her because
i mean imagine being this human being
when someone
reaches out does something nice to you
and because they don't believe the same
political ideas you
you hate them to the point where you
think that they're trying to exterminate
a whole race of people i mean
that's just absolutely insane and this
lady i wrote
when talking about this is just a
perfect byproduct and victim of this
woke algorithm that radicalized her and
made her into a person that can't even
live life normally
that that sadly is stuck in this
perpetual loop of hate and fear
that she's caught up in because she's
also writing a lot of the puff pieces
she's also manipulating a lot of the
information trying to of course
gain all the followers monetize her
clicks she's a part of this entire
system that is spinning out of control
and this is a perfect perfect example of
of going utterly crazy
this is but it's not just her no this is
just because she's prominent she writes
for the la times we hear this
but i've seen so much stuff like this
how insane
these people have gotten that you can
you can not even like maybe you're not
even a trump supporter
you'll just be like i don't know i think
everyone's kind of crazy trump's got bad
but you know he's not the worst guy in
the world and they'll still be like oh
oh you're a fascist you're far right or
you're you're what is it
far right adjacent which what does that
even what is that what does that one
mean does it mean you're just right wing
like what is that i i don't you know i'm
kind of my feelings on trump
i wasn't a big fan of his behavior his
personality but like
he wasn't evil man he's out of office he
left office
he didn't get us into any overt war he
didn't like i mean he did
escalate the drone war campaign
unfortunately but he didn't like
persecute and murder a bunch of
americans he did separate people at the
border
that was like the most terrifying
imprisonment of of people he did
on american soil that i'm aware of but
comparing him to hitler's at it it's
over the edge i mean it's in yeah but
misanthropy i don't know how to describe
it let me read this quote she said
the favors hezbollah does for people in
the cities of tyre and sedan
probably don't involve snow plows but
like other mafias
hezbollah tends to own tends to its own
the shiite sick elderly and hungry she
wrote
they offer protection and hospitality
and win loyalty that way
and they also demand devotion to their
brutal us
versus them anti-sunni cause some of us
are family the favor say
say the rest are infidels is she trying
to claim
that the people who plowed her driveway
did it so that they would force her to
like them
as like a loyalty test they really
plugged my driveway so that i would have
no choice but to
support trump they probably just like
doing they're nuts these people are
crazy
well i mean like if you think of what
most people's motivations are if it's
not for money if it's not to like
you know attract someone in particular
most of the time people do
friendly things to get some
well if it's not to obviously like for
their own
like internal benefit like they like
doing nice things for other people
because it
you know they feel good after they do it
yeah like you're doing something yeah a
lot of people do nice things for other
people
to get other people to like them it's
it's just kind of basic human nature
it's not confusing well not to us so i
would say that if you were doing
something like plowing someone's
driveway as a favor you're probably
gonna expect them to like mow your lawn
for you maybe well that's very
transactional way of looking at it
i think i think most people would not
expect
something in return when they do
something yeah we had a neighbor that
would always shovel our he'd be
shoveling his sidewalk and then he just
keep shoveling you know
shovel our sidewalk he had the shovel he
was outside so what causes this because
this is very different from say critical
race theory or critical theory
this is just i don't know what media
driven
cult psychosis i'd say it's boredom
boredom yeah i think people just
honestly don't have
enough to write about so they find the
things that bother them in their life
and boom you get a column like virginia
heffernan
who has by the way made the list and has
blocked me because of being honest
basically posting how like triggered
they are
by some trump supporters plowing their
driveway i mean come on like
if you do something nice for me i'm
gonna like you know offer you and you
know
bring you know coffee hot cocoa like you
want to hang out like
i'm i'm game for that it's just i don't
understand why some people are sort of
wired in the way that like
you gotta like flesh out everything
about that person we live in a very
deeply cynical world
i think boredom does fuel a lot of this
you know
cult-like behavior the writers are
desperate for something to write about
to make money at their jobs and so
they'll try and find something exactly
there was one funny article uh we read a
while back about like
you know uh ivanka trump's address
signifying alt-right
nash like it crammed every key word
possible in a particular article
but i think what happens is you have
these this grifter class of people in
media
who will say whatever they need to say
to pander to their cult
and then the people who are in the cult
just have no purpose
so when they see you know this person
standing atop the tower holding the
tablet saying go do these things they're
like
that's my that's my reason for being
that's my existence otherwise they don't
have anything else
so you know i've talked about this uh in
the context of jordan peterson
one of the reasons why i think they
hated him so much and still do is that
he gives purpose to many young people
not necessarily conservatives
who they're looking for something in
their lives they have no purpose and he
said
find the heaviest thing you can you can
carry and carry it he tells people to be
responsible for themselves clean their
room
well these a lot of these cult like you
know far leftists
need purposelessness in order to be the
solution to that problem
so when you have these young people who
are like i don't know what i'm alive for
what am i doing they say wokeness join
the cult be one of us and then go
finally
purpose well i actually i do i mean i
see where you're going with this because
um i think one of the
aspects that made for some for a lot of
young muslim men
and some women but mostly young muslim
men and part of the funneling the whole
radical islamic terrorism aspect
is that once you hit a certain age you
know young adulthood
he's trying to start figuring out what
your purpose is in life
you turn to religion some people turn to
it a little bit more so
not everyone everyone finds something
different but something that gives your
life meaning and purpose
when it came to a lot of these young
muslims who felt sort of
disillusioned by what was happening in
the world well
some of them you know were either say
very
um turned off by sort of the way society
or the direction of society was headed
through culture or through politics what
have you and
a lot of them and this is actually kind
of indicative of a lot of
particular terrorist suspects who have
either carried out their attack versus
uh
were caught in the middle or trying to
do commit their act
they were not like for all intents and
purposes
practicing or good muslims by the
standard of like
you know they go out partying they drink
they do drugs they'd have premarital sex
things like that and then they go you
know almost
pivot the entire 180 to
some radical ideology within in this
case islam
join up with al qaeda with isis and
basically try to give themselves some
sort of meaning
by fulfilling what they think is a
prophecy
set up by god when really it's just
obviously people taking
you know manipulating these people for
their violent political purposes
there are people who want to wield the
power and there are people who are just
desperate to have meaning in their lives
yeah
i don't blame you know i feel bad for a
lot of these people
the the people who found say jordan
peterson and decided just to
find their own path figure something out
and work hard basically just take advice
from someone who tells you to be a chill
person
and just you know be responsible those
people found a good path
probably a lot of them are probably
happy now after reading and listening to
what he had to say i'm not
saying you know dr peterson is perfect
by any stretch of the imagination but
when you've got aimless listless young
people playing video games all day just
gaining weight in their basement
and then one day someone says go for a
walk clean your room get active and they
do
they're gonna start feeling better about
themselves i mean we live in a society
that
nurtures immediate gratification and
when you see people who sort of like get
rich quick overnight whether
through you know through bitcoin or wall
street or wall street bets
or even like viral on the internet yeah
going viral on the internet
going on twitch going on twitter going
on tick tock like
these are things that you know for a lot
of young people
who aren't seeing that type of success
immediately overnight they start to
think
why not me why is this not happening to
me is there something
wrong with me there is they didn't watch
fight club
we were all told that we're gonna be
rock stars and astronauts
it's not true so you might just be a
dude in the backyard chopping wood
yeah be happy with yourself your life
find your own meeting read a book
but you can be a rock star and an
astronaut you can
you can i think the issue is you know
it's crazy
when i see these stories about bands
that break up
and people are like why would they break
up they had it all and it's like dude
you really don't understand
the amount of work and suffering that
goes into trying to maintain such high
level positions
who are apparently i'm probably messing
with the story at some capacity the dire
straits
heard these guys watching their music
video complaining about how they get
everything for free and it's like dude
it's hard work
to maintain all this stuff so bands
these high profile bands these these
famous individuals
many of them look don't get me wrong
some of them barely do anything and get
money it happens
but a lot of them are working so hard
they're like i can't do this anymore i
can't be around these people this is
toxic
every day sucks i want to be with my
family and they break up and they give
it all up
they don't want to they they'd rather
not make the money and just be the dude
in the backyard chopping lumber
case in point dylan radigan you know
dylan radford right yeah what's he doing
he's farming now right
uh i believe he was in italy last time
he's doing small-time appearances on
jimmy dore but he was a big-time msnbc
anchor
and he was also you know a friend and he
started farming
he's he started building he started
getting into
i think solar panels and sustainable
communities and
doing a lot of cool hippie stuff but he
was in the business he was
a mainline msnbc anchor and he was one
of the few people that criticized wall
street that criticized the big banks
and he dealt with the internal powers
that be at msnbc that fire anchors for
not
towing the line the agenda and he was
just disenfranchised by it but a great
person
good guy you know there are many stories
of this where stories like this where
there's somebody who seems to have it
all
and then just wants to be the dude in
the backyard shopping chopping wood
because it feels good just be out there
work with your hands do you really want
to give up your
your mind soul and body to something or
do you want to just have the freedom
there are a lot of people who who think
it must be so great the grass is always
greener
instead of just working on themselves
being happy with their own lives
and so what they do is they seek purpose
some of them will get trapped in an
addiction
addiction cycle like a video game you
know these video games offer up a
dopamine reaction when you succeed
you play the game you earn experience
points boom new level new armor new
weapon you know whatever game you're
playing
and it feels good when you get it other
people join these cult-like ideologies
because they feel like they're doing
something like they finally matter
and they won't give it up because if
they finally realize their ideology is
psychotic
like screaming at your neighbors for
literally no reason
it shatters their worldview their
purposelessness
of their they have become purposeless
you brought up a point that i'm
literally writing about in my journal
right now
when you look at people who have been
radicalized because let's be honest here
she's radicalized to a very
a big extent where she can't even take
some a nice
gesture when you look at people who are
radicalized they're usually hopeless as
you said purposeless
they're uneducated and they don't have a
family and when you see those bigger
kind of trends unfolding on a larger
scale and a lot more people being
radicalized
this truly is showing something that we
should be concerned about because when
you see
this trend keep going the way it is it's
only going to lead to more troubles
politically socially violence and uh
yeah
exactly right now this lady's like what
do i do they're being nice
well she's writing that essentially her
neighbors are being nice to her
because it's all about generating the
loyalty hey i did this for you come join
us like she's acquainted with hezbollah
what happens when she's when she she
goes even further what happens when you
have somebody
who just truly believes oh no they're
walking to my house with shovels they're
here to hurt me
and they caught a weapon or something
crazy like that you know what i mean
yeah what happens when they truly
believe there's no good intent sometimes
they'll try and set them up
and and like blackmail them and stuff
what happens people go that far i know
that's kind of crazy i think we're you
know we saw uh
there was an article chris hayes wrote
for i think it was the olynyk
where he said rural areas are getting
reliably more red
and suburban areas and urban areas are
getting reliably more blue for whatever
reason
you can even zoom in and see it the
closer you get to a city the bluer
things get and why is that even
even in red states when you find urban
centers they're blue
even in red states it's really weird and
so what's happening is that
one of the one of the things that may be
happening is that people are leaving
cities
conservatives or people who are more
likely to be right-leaning or moderate
or conservative
will go find like-minded people where
they can be comfortable
and the the the democrat liberal
leftists are doing similar things
this is going to create a space a
situation in this country
where there's no cross-communication
anymore
and it's just like you'll see someone
and be like they're evil there's also
been a huge demographic shift
over the last decade just because as i
said before
all politics are local or all politics
is local
and when you find that your local
politicians are putting
implementing policies that say go
against your values
often times they're not yeah you're
going to leave i mean just look at how
many people have left california for
texas
or for arizona and are slowly turning
those states blue
not always i mean arizona turned blue
but texas
much closer in this past election than
in years past
and when you start and this is the this
is sort of the folly when it comes to
for say for some
republicans in these states is that you
become a victim of your own success
all of a sudden they're now electing
people that don't
that are going to implement policies
that are antithetical to yours yeah
they they bring you know there was that
comic where joe rogan is walking from
california to texas
you know smiling and he's carrying a bag
on wheels in a roller bag
and it says liberal policies and there
was like a cowboy guy saying like hey
why don't you leave that where you got
it
and that's the idea you know someone
like joe rogan may be
a pretty you know mild reasonable guy
he's fairly libertarian but he is fairly
left on a lot of issues
and so he might you know he'll end up
coming and then what happens is with all
of his good intentions
he'll vote for someone who seems
moderate libertarian which will be
further left than the traditional
republican who runs in the area and then
it's just it's a slow process where the
path to hell is paved with good
intentions yeah
didn't someone compare into rush
limbaugh today yes yeah washington
washington post said that joe rogan is
the next rush limbaugh
are you kidding me do you want to talk
about it i could see it yeah i mean
both bulbs sometimes check us out okay
so we we do have this story from the
washington post
it says rush limbaugh is ailing and so
is conservative talk radio industry
it's from paul farhi ah this guy this uh
we
we know paul and uh in in in this
he actually brings up this one point
about uh
basically the article is saying that
talk radio is is on the decline and that
means conservatives are
are in trouble but he says one very
important thing
the shift makes someone like comedian
joe rogan a
libertarian with a hugely popular
podcast quote
the next rush limbaugh says paul matsco
the author of the radio right
how a band of broadcasters took on the
federal government and built the modern
conservative movement well okay so far
he isn't himself saying that joe rogan
is the next rush limbaugh but that
is a heck of a statement to be made i
would i mean like in terms of
impact maybe i mean rush limbaugh has
been a force on the right
but joe rogan is not a force on the
right no joe rogan's not a force on the
right but he is a force
true but you know i guess in the idea of
influence in talk shows but
larry king had an influence in talk
shows yeah it's a wild stretch i mean he
could have said howard stern he could
have said black people
people listen to rogan like a spiritual
guide kind of like how rush limbaugh
the problem is rogan doesn't puppeteer
the talking points he doesn't go along
with the agenda he actually questioned
things and he tries to rationalize them
instead of just pushing up propaganda
and that's why he's such a battering ram
yeah exactly that's why it's so
dangerous is because you get someone who
inspires you to
question the narrative and question
things as they are
questioning authority who wants but who
in authority wants that
rush limbaugh is a conservative with
conservative opinions
and when he tells stories and he talks
he's talking
it's not for for the most part but you
did explain to me
as off the show that there's no such
thing as the left and right anymore
it is oh that's yeah it is it is the
occult
it's the cult and then and then the
knight cult so right now we're looking
at the example of
joe rogan's part of the not cult but he
has his own cult
like following a few months if you want
to make that that uh comparison
and then but he's challenging everything
within that world cult for the most part
right
so yeah so i guess in that in that case
in that stance you're probably right
isn't it the weirdest thing that left
and right has nothing to do with
i don't i don't even you know look we
were talking earlier you
you know i said there's no real left and
right anymore you agree you said it's a
horseshoe and i said it's a jackson
pollock painting
it's just i don't know who's what who's
where so i can come out and be like
all of my you know policy positions have
been traditional liberal but
i think the democrats are manipulative
and they're lying to people and the
media is lying too
and that's a right-wing position
apparently so i guess
i think we'll be all like by 2069
nice we'll be all uh a like a
homogenized like
you know we talk about the mixing bowl
that's when we'll all be homogenized
everybody literally
has a position takes every single
position on everything like hillary
clinton what do you mean like she takes
a position and everything
yeah i mean there are a lot of things
where i'm like i don't know
you know keystone pipeline's a good
example the left says it's causing oil
spills and it's like okay and the right
says freight delivery causes more
oil spills so keystone actually is an
improvement
there we mentioned this on the show the
other day there's this meme about the us
government spent
millions of dollars developing a pen
that can be used in zero gravity so they
can write while they're in outer space
the russians use the pencil and then
everyone laughs
and these leftists share the memes
saying it was such a simple solution in
america waste all this money
and then the new meme now is someone
writing a correction saying
using a pencil can get particulate
matter from the pencil into the air
which can be dangerous for the
filtration system and what you are
breathing
and so because they need a purified
environment it is dangerous to use a
pencil
so the u.s created a pressurized pen to
use in outer space
for safety purposes it makes a ton of
sense when you don't understand and you
think you're smarter the simple solution
sounds like it's right
but in reality it wasn't makes me keep
thinking about this where when
a new person goes from california to
texas they want to impose what they
think is right and often
what you think is right isn't so that's
when like
when peop when you want to push your
beliefs whatever they are you got to
like look at history and look at the
patterns and think of yourself as part
of a pattern
i just think of myself as a dumbass
you're not a dumbass
louis because again you have to
understand there's a lot of stuff we
don't know about
and and a lot of people think that they
know everything we don't
learn about let's let's talk about the
the subtle erosion
when it comes to politics uh with joe
rogan being the example of like the new
right
if we're talking about the left being
the cult and the right being the not
cult then
yeah i guess as strange as it might
sound joe rogan may very well be the
next rush limbaugh
the only difference is joe is talking to
people
he's he's not for the most part uh
getting up there and for hours talking
about how he feels about what's going on
so
there's a difference but in terms of
policy changes that's going to affect
this country
you know so so we're out here in the
middle of nowhere i've gone to a few gun
shops
and i was talking to this one guy and he
was saying oh we got all these liberals
moving in now you know because since
covid
and the riots and now they're coming to
buy guns and i'm like and i laughed and
i'm like i'm one of them and then
he gave me this look he was just like oh
and i'm like here's my you know
former id from this you know very blue
place and i was like no don't look at me
man i'm not voting
and i was like because i don't know i i
lived in this place and it got bad
and now i'm coming new to a new place
i'll defer to you guys
and then he was like no just vote for
you know the people we tell you to vote
for and i was like
i'll just leave it to you i'm not going
to get involved but here's what happens
joe's a good dude
he's got a lot of good ideas and he's
fairly rational right
but he'll come in and and i mean with
the utmost respect
i don't think his intention is going to
be i'm going to turn this place deep
blue and make it as bad as california
because he fully understands why
california is bad so he's pr he's
probably soured on a lot of the policies
of california
that are deep blue however there are
probably some things where he's like
look i like that texas does a lot of
these things but there are some things i
think should change legalize weird
that's the slow erosion there's issues
pertaining to family there's issues
pertaining to you know marijuana for
instance
that can lead to bigger changes down the
road and as an individual person you
might not realize the correlation
between
one policy and the next so you might
think it's no big deal
that i'm saying we should allow or not
allow this one particular thing not
realizing
it is just one domino being knocked over
which eventually ripples down the line
so let's say you you know want think
marijuana should be legalized you vote
for it
now all of a sudden you get a bunch of
dispensaries popping up and a bunch of
industries from california and colorado
blue areas
move in and set up massive businesses
and relocate their employees sending in
more deep blue voters
there's things like that it's not it's
not so cut and dry yeah i mean
you just got to get republicans to start
smoking weed and you got no problem
right
they'll become libertarians overnight
psilocybin yeah
you know you just gotta you just gotta
like slowly push that on them just be
like it's okay
like you can i laugh and joke but like
if everyone took
a dose of psilocybin i think this world
would be like drastically altered for
the better
i don't know about for the better
communication or they could freak out
and have a total like that will probably
happen
again when you're talking about
psilocybin your own personal decision
some people have
really great amazing eye-opening uh
experiences like bill hicks
some people freak the hell out and have
horrible experiences
because their self-control is trying to
limit to their kind of expansion and
they're fighting each other and that
fighting is hurt it creates
they're already insane they're already
out of control and crazy so like
yeah that's oversimplifying wrong that's
oversimplifying war
we don't have war because someone's just
crazy there are reasons behind why they
declare war and typically it's over true
you could have
like the berserkers the history was they
would take like
crazy psychoactives and then go into
battle but they can't point out so you
can have a society that's on
psychoactives and violence so you're
right
right but what i'm saying is you said
there would be world peace if people did
psilocybin
well communication is what really brings
it right now i'll tell you learn
communications you could you could take
a world leader i wanted
and have them take shrooms and they're
still going to say but my country needs
oil
maybe and maybe not though i don't know
man you see outside the box on that
stuff so you think that
a country that's heavily sanctioned like
iran for instance
and their people are starving and their
currency is hyperinflating that the
ayatollah takes shrooms and also he's
gonna be like
let my people die he'd probably be like
well oil is feeding my people so i can't
stop right now because they'll die
but as opposed to maybe the butt wasn't
there before at least i think
i think you know it's like saying a
father would sacrifice his kids if he
took shrooms i just don't see it
sacrifice them why let them die
like a leader of their people in their
country are not going to abandon them
simply because they had a trip
you know what i mean but those are two
kind of extremes and you really kind of
have to experience it
to understand what kind of happens to
you there's a lot of possibilities in
this kind of larger spectrum
but there have been a lot of scientific
studies especially with micro dosing
showing that it does actually help your
mental cognitive functions
increase and help cure a lot of ptsd and
a lot of other internalized kind of
depression linked issues sure that that
couldn't be solved with other issues but
mushrooms specifically did in particular
studies so but
the issue i see is if you've got a
nation
and they're being besieged by another
nation repeatedly
and their people are being killed doing
shrooms won't change that fact that
they're being threatened and attacked
and they will respond in kind
it won't change the the fact right that
there's a siege they won't like lift the
siege but
it will change the way you view and your
tactics so so let me ask you if i was
throwing rocks at your face would you
stop me
yeah if you took shrooms and then the
next day i threw rocks to your face
would you stop me
so what how come there's no peace
there's external factors in war that's
not related to what you do with your
shrooms
someone taking psychedelics is not going
to change well i would stop you in
different ways
i would depending on depending on the
situation i just don't you would build a
wall
no i might throw it back at you you get
about to catch it or you know you'd
build a wall with the rocks that you're
throwing in the wall i have a simple
statement
that i saw today in a meme so it's now
my philosophy that i live by
and it says do not harm take no ish and
i think you know
yin and yang i think i think if people
have reasonable approaches like that i
think
they could go about things especially if
they have hope if they have their minds
opened up to new perspectives it could
go along
in a way that could be a lot more
productive and conducive than doing it
just the old-fashioned way and when you
look at psychedelic mushrooms they
usually help people realize those other
possibilities but again
not a medical doctor not recommending it
to you i know a lot of people that had
really bad trips
and had psychosis and dealt with some
really negative impacts
so if you're if you are going to do
something do your own homework do your
own research talk to some professionals
uh especially on this topic because it
is a very important one that you need to
take seriously
and not just decide from a youtuber and
i'll take a bunch of money so
so let's follow up on the initial
conversation
you know i see a lot of people moving to
texas and i'm just like why
you know i've had people say to me like
you should move to texas and i was like
nah i'm not going to go to
austin yeah everybody's moving to austin
didn't elon musk go there yep
he's right outside austin elon and joe
and and who else went there is chappelle
down there is he just too much
no
california but a lot of people are going
to texas a lot of smaller youtubers but
still like prominent personalities are
in texas
warm that's nice but will texas is it
do you guys really think this will make
texas turn blue do you think siraj oh
uh i don't know if it will i think i've
always thought it would it would turn
blue within like the next 10 years not
this election
um but look just by
pure voting numbers if you looked at how
hillary clinton lost to donald trump i
think he lost she lost by like 800 000
votes
uh beth o'rourke in the 2018 midterm
lost to
ted cruz by like 200 000 votes and then
i think
around in in this 2020 election
i think it was somewhere around a
ballpark of 100 to 150 000
um but it wasn't the it wasn't the shift
that i thought it was going to be
that was going to be even much closer
than that but
it's you know anything is possible
there's probably
texas is probably going to do something
that's going to alienate all the libs
and they're going to
they're going to leave like they did in
georgia think about this though
i mean the republican party today is
very different from where it was four
years ago and four years before that
it's being pulled to the left so for all
we know the democrats of this year will
be republicans in 2022
and then texas will stay red and
everyone's like oh look it's red but
it's actually
pretty far left yeah i mean the thing is
about yeah and that's the thing about
how progressives view
the democratic party in general and that
they are very much
the party they're very much like the
republican party of like the george w
bush years yeah to me it's also really
going to
depend on the immigration especially the
immigration that joe biden
is letting in and that's going to have a
huge tremendous effect that of course
will support a lot of democrats
and also what's happening on the
campuses i mean we have to understand
there's
a new kind of youth coming out directly
from universities and they're
inspired they're uh individuals that are
taught a certain way of thinking that
is becoming prevalent that is supported
by the corporations that is supported by
hollywood that is supported by silicon
valley that is kind of eroding any form
of
the old kind of fashion way of living i
just realized why it's so important to
stand up and speak your mind and be
honest
it's not to change your minds it's the
kids the young 14 and 13
the impressionable people that are
forming their belief of what the world
is
it's affecting them like that's why it's
important to build culture
that's why it's important to do fun
things that inspire young people
and one of the problems i guess with
like talk radio is it's for people who
are already in the know
it's not but then you youtube shows
where 13 year olds log on that's why
it's awesome
[Music]
it's funny but then you for the most
part don't watch political commentary
they don't
this show is different you know they're
on tick yeah
and you know i apparently get like
millions of views
epic yeah look i am a nobody i mean
i i but i have young people reach out to
me all the time which is crazy thinking
that i'm like some sort of like
influence in their life and that means a
lot
because they say you are you are yeah no
it's and and i mean you start to
think about like what kind of impact you
actually are having on certain people
and it's tremendous the chinese kind of
implications here when it comes to tick
tock and also our
campuses and university is also
something that i think is really
prevalent
that we should be talking about because
according to campus reform they just
released an article according to their
source
who allegedly works in ice it was that
joe biden our president
just recently quietly ended a trump
policy where universities had to
publicly release their ties to the
chinese government
and to specifically the chinese
confucius institutions
and now under this alleged new directive
according to
campus reform they no longer have to do
that and opening the door for chinese
propaganda yes and when you look at the
influence that the chinese government
has been
expanding all over the world and
particularly in our institutions it
really makes you wonder
especially when you see the result of of
a quote university education on the
young children that are coming out
and their behavior in the world which is
i would say somewhat fairly
uh you know not to be too hyperbolic but
but essentially destructive to
our way of life well let's i want to
expand on this but i want to start with
this next story we have check this out
from cbs 8. researchers say voters are
leaving the republican party
recent studies show the republican party
is losing voters after the riots on
capitol hill last month
they say voting experts at the
university of florida say thousands of
voters are no longer registered with the
gop
they say far more republicans than
democrats are changing their
registration
and it's happening here in san diego
county too the interaction of the us
capital on january 6 is something most
people thought they'd never witness
now political research says the fallout
from that day shows
thousands of registered voters fleeing
the republican party quote
these republicans are rejecting trumpism
a brand that they see continue to lead
the party
even after his defeat and california
secretary of state's office shows
over 33 thousand voters have left the
gop since the right of the capital
in san diego county more than 4 700
republicans have defected
now i i want to ask a question how do
they know these people are leaving
because of the riots
that's i was just about to say that
maybe maybe they're leaving because
trump's out and they don't care about
the republican party
i think i think it's more of the fact
that republicans have been
the the establishment has taken over the
republican party and they did not do
everything they possibly could to keep
trump in office well i think it's the
way around i think trump
infected the establishment like he
forced his way in
and then as soon as they had the
opportunity to get rid of him they did
right no
they definitely did i'm totally with you
on that one yeah but i'm saying that
one of the reasons and i've talked to a
number of trump supporters who are
you know on the fgop bandwagon
they believe that the republican party
didn't do enough
to keep trump in office believing
obviously that the election was stolen
and that when it comes to uh
how the gop is now they
sort of embraced it they embraced
letting trump
be expelled from office right and didn't
do enough what what what do republicans
do
what do they fight for is there is like
a specific issue republicans are like
this is our issue
this the one thing that sort of unites
them all together
limited government what does that mean
and when do they vote for it
hey that's a great question because i'm
looking you know i'm i'm thinking of
that that weekend
video you know from the super bowl
halftime show like where where all this
where all the limited government
republicans at one thing we talk about
quite a bit is that you
you can name very specific things that
progresses and democrats say they must
have
right natural path to naturalization you
know public option or universal health
care
gun control you know what they're saying
we must
have now and the republicans are saying
don't do that don't do that but they're
not doing anything themselves
right no they've always been the party
i've mostly been the party of no
hold your horses yeah not even know just
well think about what the term of
being what does what does the term
conservative really mean is someone who
has always sort of just played it safe
not doing anything drastic trying to
keep with tradition that's
largely what conservatives have always
been about and they're getting arms
manufacturing deals well bribes whatever
you want to call them
funding and uh oil the oil industry is
behind them so they
don't want it to change they want to
right continue the gravy train
means a lot everything comes down to
money i wonder how this is going to
impact
the future because before this segment
we were talking about propaganda
universities affecting our kids
trump brought in new voters he brought
in a lot of younger voters too
i i went to a bunch of trump rallies and
i talked to people you know to young men
who are like 20
and they said political correctness was
the issue why they decided to vote
republican
not much else trump was actually
fighting for specific things
sort of he represented certain things he
was fighting
to end these free trade agreements to
bolster american manufacturing that was
something finally people saw and they
agreed with
whereas the republicans were basically
like just not the democrat right
now we have this wave you know young
people every every every year
there's a wave of you know generation of
young people who are now eligible to
vote
these people these young people are now
entering the ranks of
american voters with a crippled gop
that people are leaving and don't care
for anymore
so if they are conservative or at least
not far left
where do they go do we ultimately see
the rise of a new political party or
several or what here's the thing
when it comes to people actually
entering the voting booth most people
think about
what what their vote actually means like
is it actually
going to be counted in a way that it
matters
and when they think about the dichotomy
the two-party system
republican democrat they realize that
they can't always just throw away their
ballot i think most people when they
enter the voting booth
think they're going to vote for someone
that if if they hate the other party
they're going to vote for the party
that's
in opposition um that that's kind of
that is probably the most simplest
explanation i can give
because they may hate that particular
party that they're voting for
but they'll do it to try to stave
whatever may happen whatever may
change from the other party taking over
right i would ask please don't vote with
hate
in the future vote for not against no
you just vote for the lesser of two
evils i mean that's what the media tells
us to do that's clearly what we should
do
also another thing to kind of think
about with this news article a lot of
these polls are usually
very very wrong and two that's true
usually the conservatives are very
underrepresented
in them so the polling industry is is an
industry that i absolutely do not trust
well but it's not falling this is the
actual hard numbers from the secretary
of state's office
tracking party membership well yeah well
yeah but but even when it comes to that
we have to understand
republicans and conservatives usually
are the types not to be very public
about who they support or why they
support
and a lot of times they they surprise
people at the polls because
they actually vote but they don't tell
anyone who they voted for that's why a
lot of the exit polls a lot of the other
polls were wrong
and even though they might be
transferring parties right now it still
doesn't directly represent
yeah it still doesn't i mean i think
they're just disenfranchised
disenfranchised not just by trump not
just by the republicans but uh how can
you not be disenfranchised
with joe biden i mean i if you're not
maybe if you're not paying attention and
if you're in la la land which a lot of
people
are but if you're paying attention you
are absolutely disenfranchised with joe
biden
i mean biden is remarkably doing things
that everybody hates
yeah he rescinds this rule on chinese
propaganda he rescinded so he says
i'm sorry suspended the rule and chinese
propaganda he suspended a rule keeping
china out of our electrical grid and
like
why so that's got conservatives pissed
off but the left is saying
he promised two thousand dollar checks
he promised 50 dollar minimum wage he's
not doing any of those things either so
he's basically building a coalition
against him
yeah he banned the term china virus
because
he wanted to fight coveted racism i mean
he banned the language
as he's making sure americans to get
into the united states have to get a
covet test
but if you're a migrant you don't even
get coveted when you cross the u.s
border
but american citizens returning back to
their country you have to have a
covenant what if these people coming in
these migrants have coveted
yes yeah that's the point that's the
point that tucker carlson was talking
about yesterday in this first segment
which is something that i i think shows
you who
biden is really interested in this
disenfranchising of conservative voters
is worrisome
because you've got a bunch of people now
feeling like there's no outlet and
they're hearing things like what luke is
saying you mean if i fly in i gotta get
a test
but these people can just walk across
the border no problem
and joe biden is is creating a pathway
for these people but making it harder
for americans
that's going to make people lose it it
really does feel like the joke you know
this is the joke we've been making they
keep throwing more at us just to see
how far we're willing to take it i i i'm
a little skeptical about that type of
story because
you you might hear it happen at one
particular checkpoint but it might not
it might be the exception not the rule
because i mean think about all these
detention centers that are housing a lot
of these migrants i mean
we talked obviously we talked about like
the child separation policy in 2018
which is
awful policy we should pull the story up
it's on the daily mail they also covered
it and they wrote
a story about how migrants are not being
tested
but uh american citizens who are coming
back have to have a
you know negative test in order to enter
the country i mean just think about i
mean because a lot of these detention
centers are controlled by hhs
well now they're no no no they're not
detention centers they're expansion
centers they're expensive
so they're okay that's some kind of
lingo that they're using now
what is that what does that even mean
overflow they're over overflow centers
okay
they're overflowing and so we have to
figure out are those overflow centers
controlled by hhs or by dhs
because those two those two uh federal
agencies
basically control the flow of people
into the united states
and a lot of the detention facilities
that we saw that we thought were
controlled by
dhs or actually controlled by hhs that's
health and human services
yes that's that's the that's the the
federal agency that's
been trying to do all the covid
operation warp speed vaccine
basically the federal government's
response to all of this has basically
been controlled by hhs
sorry sorry i i didn't know that was a
very warm keep keep going i was just
wondering if you found the artist dhs
well i found a partner talking about
tucker carlson blasting biden for
releasing thousands of migrants into the
us without giving them covet tests
as texas sheriff says the policy will
create irreparable harm
and that's that's that's i mean that's
the gist of it that's it that needs
investigation that that is
that it sounds too crazy to be real but
again we live in the crazy world
[Laughter]
these these people who are leaving the
republican party probably were barely in
the republican party
when i was uh when i was in florida
there was a trump rally in fort
lauderdale
and i was just talking some random trump
supporters i i talked to not one
one republican i i talked to a small
handful of people maybe just
just shy of a dozen and they all
basically said the same thing
oh i'm i'm not in any party or anything
like that i think oh i i've never voted
before
i was just going to say that trump
supporters trump is not a republican
he's not a conservative
he ran as a republican but
even you know the the most conservative
people will tell you trump is not a
conservative he is
he is a nationalist populist he is in
many ways an opportunist
and i think the the greatest analogy i
ever heard
uh about trump is that he's like a couch
whoever sits on him last that's what's
left on his brain
like that's what he's thinking about so
like whoever gets in his ear the last
the the last person who gets in his ear
that's one that's on his mind that's
what's probably go
he's going to be tweeting about or well
he can't tweet anymore but that's what
he would be talking about
he could go on gab r.i.p in peace but he
won't
depress i think you're right that not
maybe not that we need a new political
party but people want to do that they
want to we need it
and we need it what i think is that if
we don't start it literally
me and you like if we don't start it it
won't happen
i mean that's the problem i'm not
interested in being involved in a
political that's the thing
everyone hates nobody i don't want to be
a politician i don't hate myself right
exactly
like that you have to find someone who
particularly
loathes themselves in order to start
that people
you need uh you ever see that i love
this this is my favorite references of
late the futurama episode about the
clone presidents
was it john jackson and jack johnson i
think your three cent titanium tax goes
too far
well i think your three cent titanium
titanium tax doesn't go too far enough
for the same person fry is like they
look like the same person
and then leela's like it's because they
are that's that's what we have and and
that's what you need
you need somebody who has no real
thoughts or opinions and you hand them a
stack of papers saying here are the
things you have to say and they go okay
and they get votes could you build a
system where that it totally satiates
the military industrial complex
and everybody involved but somehow
creates a system that will evolve us out
of it
i don't know green party
so like with with energy would it be
like an elect election no
i'm saying the actual green party maybe
i don't know
they seem to be the only party saying
that they we don't need the military
industrial complex but i guess
i i guess i guess the libertarian party
might be on on the same wavelength but
yeah but we've all seen the meme with
the scraggly looking fox
you know that's true you think you'd
have a better chance starting a new
party
or co-opting like the green party you
have to go out there this is why trump
didn't
trump was actually part of the reform
party when in 2000 and he left it
because they were too
extreme and then he joined the gop later
on
after being a democrat for so long
because
he knew he figured out a way
to speak towards a lot of different
people from all different parts of the
then we're talking about political
spectrum because obviously the political
spectrum doesn't exist anymore
but people all across the spectrum
and find something that resonates with
them
and it is literally as simple as
these people are out to get you i'm in
the way
that's why they hate me oh and
that was sort of he was a knock against
the entire establishment both democrat
and republican because he was just not
part of it he was the outsider
uh he was the billionaire outsider who
came in
like a wrecking ball miley cyrus
basically saying i am going to change
the entire system
and then what ended up happening was he
because he was basically laughed out of
the prime well he wasn't left out of the
primary but people
you know did not take his candidacy
seriously from the get-go because of
whatever rhetoric he said you know
starting from his very first
political rally um
he couldn't hire the right advisors and
he ended up getting people like carter
page and george papadopoulos who didn't
really know what they were doing
and then they get wrapped up in this
whole like russia probe but then he
couldn't fill
his his actual cabinet with people who
actually believed in him
they were just opportunists trying to
basically get a job
and pardon for someone they knew or a
pardon for someone they knew
but there were just as many
opportunities that surrounded
trump president trump than president
trump himself
it's just i mean ever every so so
everybody was working against him i was
reading something earlier that
when he was trying to draft his
executive orders initially
the olc was just not like basically
office of legal counsel yeah yeah they
were supposed to be saying okay here's
how you can make your executive order
work
and they would purposefully leave holes
so that it could be destroyed in the
courts
i don't know if that's true i was
something i was reading no there is
there was incentive to make sure that
trump failed
within the republican party because they
they realized that he took control of
he was he was the republican party when
he was president
everything was about him he was the
center of the universe
and establishment republicans were on on
the outside
and they realized that if if
actually democrats took a lesson from
from from republicans in 2016.
when bernie was winning all those states
in their early primaries he won what he
win he went
well iowa still hasn't decided uh he won
uh new hampshire and then he won uh
uh nevada um was there a third state
in there before i don't know but anyways
he had enough delicates as if he won
iowa
and then south carolina came up what
happened right right before super
tuesday
so joe biden predictably won south
carolina
but then the establishment decided they
were not going to let
an insurgency from bernie sanders happen
so they all coalesced behind joe biden
yeah amy klobuchar michael bloomberg
pete budajes
all dropping out in the span of like two
days and endorsing joe biden what
happened on on tuesday
super tuesday he won almost
i think all but two states and
that was it was because he the the other
candidates were splitting the vote yeah
exactly but
they realized that this is what happened
this was the following the the
republican party the republican
establishment i should say
in 2016 is that they thought you know
you had the marco rubio you had the ted
cruz you had
john kasich he had scott walker all of
them thought they could take on trump
and he just picked them off one by one
if they all coalesce behind a particular
establishment candidate
they probably would not have nominated
donald trump plus trump was fun
it was very fun watching him make fun of
jeb and turn people into memes yeah
calling rand paul ugly
well yeah even elizabeth warren wasn't
with bernie she was still sticking
around and everyone was like hey
elizabeth you're kind of hurting bernie
here with all of this and
that was the plan yeah so and it's
amazing how people believe elizabeth
warren was like progressive
she's what did i say she's hillary
clinton wearing bernie sanders mask
she's the only one that actually even
said something about social media and
the big tech oligarchs right and then
she stopped
so it's like she came out of the defense
of wall street during the during the
game stopper
yeah and they were when they were
challenging the hedge fund she's like
who are these people what are they doing
oh yeah great progressive elizabeth
warren defender of wall street
yeah now elizabeth warren um she has got
in quite a bit of flack from the bernie
crowd for
for her role in sort of undermining
bernie's candidacy
but if you also remember even from the
beginning primaries they were screwing
bernie over there was no declared winner
during the first primary in iowa
and and who got it booted judge uh but
but again it was so close and because he
was close they did
just very similar things they postponed
it they killed the next
primary until more news came in because
again
the person who wins the first primaries
always gets the big bump
always gets a big push and it was very
close for bernie getting it
and then they they kind of squish the
poop now again not a fan of bernie
i i really don't like his policies i
think he really really hurt a lot of his
supporters especially with how
hillary treated him and how he endorsed
hillary how he played the game
but still it's important to call out
that he still represents sort of a
populist idea
that does have some merit that does have
some credibility and it resonates with a
lot of people so that's what connects
trump that's what connects bernie the
larger populist ideas of course
he gave up and i would say trump gave up
as well uh you could make both arguments
both of them gave up on
on the people on their larger kind of
populist energy that trump put them
behind
trump fought for years and it was only
at the very end when he realized it was
over yeah but it was all egotistical it
was all self-absorbed and when you're
when you're coming from that perspective
it's very easy to manipulate someone
when they care so much about how they
look
i'll i'll tell you what it was because
the way i describe it all the time it
was the populists leading bernie sanders
a politician to the gates of the ivory
tower and bernie banging the door and
saying libyan
and then donald trump was a bull just
like stomping about and then
when bernie sanders kept banging on the
door they just dumped buckets on his
head and
then they were like bernie we'll let you
in if you stop banging on the door and
he's like all right let me in and i'll
stop fighting you
and then the ball just smashed through
the door started running around smashing
everything up
so when i saw trump go in i was like
well look the worst case scenario for
the left
is that trump fumbles around for another
four years but it cripples the
establishment
and opens the door for a real insurgent
leftist candidate but they couldn't do
it
that i i was like as soon as you let in
joe biden they will fortify their
defenses and you will
never never break their their their
system ever again
they did it literally in dc they're
fortifying the capital with
with military yeah they're still there
the national guard isn't supposed to
leave until like
end of march well until the end of the
engagement
trials that are happening right now i
remember uh listening to npr
as i was driving today they were
treating it like it was their super bowl
they loved every moment they're calling
it shot by shot this is the same network
by the way that was calling on ca
cia officials to explain to them how
counter insurgency should work against
domestic wrong thinkers uh aka other
trump supporters and they were arguing
that
you know the cia guy was like we need to
take down trump and and
and you see npr with their coverage
today
hinting at that trying to push for that
trying to spin as much information as
they could
uh just to push that larger perspective
i mean which is kind of crazy
we haven't really talked about
impeachment in this uh
not entirely yeah i know nobody's really
interested i mean like i'm sure you've
talked about it tirelessly before but
obviously this is just an attempt to
make sure that he never becomes a threat
again
but it's not even it's not so the
argument trump's legal team is making
is that impeachment is to remove
and prevent from holding office again
both not one
it doesn't say and or and so that's
their legal argument even if they do
convict him
he can still run again and nothing will
stop him it won't are you sure
so there's there's the argument that if
he's convicted
he uh he can't run again but the league
trump's legal team is making the
argument that it has to remove him and
as a private citizen
they have no authority to say he can't
run again so you can't get to b without
a
yeah so that's their argument so here's
what i predict will happen
doesn't it say somewhere in criminal
statute that a anyone who destroys
public record can't hold office
there was like a big thing about that um
are you talking about like the white
house logs or something like that
there uh there if there are there's like
some law pertaining to the destruction
of public documents
oh you're talking about this twitter no
no no no no like if
the secretary's it would be like destroy
their emails or something like
yes exactly like the secretary of state
or someone else destroyed the secretary
of state technically the secretary of
state
has never been found to have done it i
guess is the point
when when the email thing was happening
a lot of people were saying hillary
clinton
she caught she told this company to wipe
these servers
destroying public emails emails that
should have been released to the public
at it you know from due to her role in
the secretary of state
and thus she would be disqualified from
holding office nobody cared
that it the setup doesn't work like this
it doesn't work that way
you know you could have somebody
literally break the law and and come on
how many politicians actually go to jail
for the crimes they commit
how many times have we heard stories
about insider trading or other corrupt
activities and it's like oh
dirty what about the senator who was
accused of flying to of to another
country to be with underage
hookers and the legal argument was well
it wasn't illegal in that country and
the u.s has no jurisdiction anyway
now i'm not saying it was definitively
it wasn't the platform yeah
but it's like this guy got reelected
people in this country don't who are you
talking about
who went who that who would hook her
over who goes overseas john f kennedy
is there no there is a sitting u.s
senator who was accused
of being with underage women
of the night in a another country you
know do you remember which country it
was
i don't know what to say colombia was it
bahamas or something
but it's legal there so they didn't make
a big well that was one of the legal
arguments apparently
that this never happened but even if it
did it's not illegal there and you have
no jurisdiction to confront him over it
it was it was it was bob menendez of new
jersey oh that's right
yeah it was it was it was never i want
to make it clear
it was never definitively proven they
were accusations but the idea
like nobody cares you could literally
there are so many people who have
look there are some people who have been
you know charged with crimes and they
resigned dominican republic dominican
republic there you go
so my understanding is it was never
proven it was just yeah no accusations
or whatever
yeah but the story is weird like these
women said like it happened
and then all of a sudden they like
recanted their story in a very strange
circumstance
or something like that i've got mixed
feelings on the law and
executing the law like i'm kind of i'm
kind of chaotic like
if if bad i don't want to support bad
laws so i'm reticent to like get the law
get the police involved get the law i
feel like we can work it out as humans
without i mean
think about like the civil rights
movement that was all about that was a
movement built around
trying to change bad laws i mean there's
nothing wrong with that
i i think i think it's a noble i think
like the the works of like dr martin
luther king jr the freedom riders
like they were able to actually enact
change
through peaceful protests of course
there were some obviously who probably
didn't think that was the the mode to go
down
but um i mean the the thing is
you're always going to have laws that
are not good exactly which makes me
reticent to use the law to prosecute all
these people like tim's saying
no one really cares do people commit
commit crimes but because they're in
positions of power they're not executed
not executed but the laws the laws the
punishment is not executed funny funny
and that's and that's the the problem
with like what late stage capitalism and
the the come on laws are for poor people
yeah exactly
and i'm kind of understand i don't want
to use law to destroy
someone it just makes me feel bad but
it's there for a reason
and the reason our society has survived
as long as because we adhere to our
laws our self-agreed upon laws right
kind of we're at the point now where
it's just like a given that rich people
can do it they want
you just buy your way out of jail well
at least well it's not even that it's
like when when rich people do get
convicted of crimes it's usually a fine
they're like you gotta pay 10 million
ibm
horrible thing and they've got to pay a
billion uh 100 million dollars and it's
like they made 3.6 million
my favorite ever sketch from dave
chappelle was when he
switched the roles of like a wall street
banker being treated like a drug dealer
through the criminal justice system
the drug dealer i.e dave chappelle being
treated like he was a wall street banker
or white-collar criminal
and it was just like you know basically
and my favorite bit was the the judge
sentencing that wall street banker to
you know life in prison you'll have
plenty of time to lift weights
and convert to islam
dave chappelle is a genius man yeah but
you know look there's it
there's a really interesting idea some
countries will give people speeding
tickets based on their income
it's a percentage and not right germany
does that that's an interesting concept
because if you make a million dollars a
year you're like i don't want to speed
and pay a hundred thousand dollar fine
or you know it wouldn't be that high
it'd be like 10 grand or something
and then if you're poor it's gonna be
like three or four bucks something small
because it has to impact you in the u.s
let me tell you something fascinating or
i'll give you chicago for example
i used to live in lake view right by
wrigley field love that area and
whenever there would be a cubs game
every street would be
cars parked wrapping around in every
possible space blocking driveways
they did not care the idea was you can't
find parking in lakeview for a cubs game
and it's cheaper to pay a hundred bucks
for a ticket than it is to find a valet
or to find a parking garage the ticket
you got from the cops was just the
ticket for parking
wow so it was like they factored in
their budget they didn't care
they're like they wouldn't tow mostly no
because there was too many cars
yeah i mean civil disobedience yeah
it was just that that's that's that's
the system now it's like when everyone
speeds you can't pull everybody over
they might single somebody out
but people will come out and they'll see
tickets everywhere and they'll be like
that's the customer american spirit
like if i was going to park in a garage
it'd be 50 bucks screw it i'll pay 75.
i told you whatever i want that's you
know that's why chicago's the lawless
place it is because people won't pay
their favorite party
chicago's crooked man it's bad yeah
i've been to a lot of cities in the
united states and i've been to a lot of
places in the world and chicago
is they call it the windy city because
of the politicians blue hot air
exactly it was all corruption and all
lies wonder why chicago of all places
you know it's really funny i once got an
argument with someone about chicago
being the windy city
and they're arguing with me that it was
literally windy which it is
not really pretty okay in the winter
it's the wind tunnels between buildings
yeah kind of new york has those too it's
just not
really that as windy as new york it's
it's it which is negligibly windy
relative to most cities
and so they're like it's the windy city
because it's windy i'm like no it isn't
because all the politicians are corrupt
the last three governors went to prison
that's for real and then they're like no
it's cause i'm like didn't even argue
with me man this city is so corrupt
we had one incident where a meter maid
gave a cop a parking ticket so he
grabbed her by the throat and slammed
her up against the side of a building
and screamed in her face
there were a bunch of off-duty cops who
went to a bar and brutally just
mercilessly
beat the bartender woman because she was
telling them they had too many drinks
and they say chivalry is dead right
chicago's got
problems it's like cold so people are
angry um it's not new york so it's not
as centralized you know it's kind of the
wild west or at least
it's it is it is you got gangs running
around and the cops are like
ruthless because of the gangs and i i i
can understand why the cops are so
you know uh like just having nothing to
do with it but then you can't oppress
someone's rights because you're mad the
gangs are overrunning certain parts of
the city and you got a bad beat
it just it just becomes a dirty city man
it's
a great time chicago i lived there for
like four years
you know chicago still has dry areas
like neighborhoods no
you can't have alcohol from prohibition
yeah that's crazy where
uh i don't know exactly but i remember
when i lived near um wicker park
there's one area not too far from there
where there's no bars oh my god that was
nothing like my chicago experience no
wicker wicker park has a ton of bars
but but like maybe like a mile west
there was this area
it's like i don't know what the name of
it was but there were no bars and so
everybody would go to this one bar
just outside of this area snake room
what was it called snake hit did you
ever go to snake pit no there's
there's more than one there's too many
bars yeah snake that was awesome but i
used to go to this pizza place called
big tony's and we would get jardiner
pizza and that is oh that's the best
jardinera pizza man people are probably
listening to the show like jardinero
what does that mean what is it
it's not the deep dish is it no no no no
that's tourist pizza man yeah nobody
eats that's garbage now we get square
cut
and jardinera is it's a celery carrots
jalapeno and i think cauliflower and
it's pickled
and they put it on the pizza they bake
it in
yeah they put it on like italian beef
sandwiches soak it in vinegar and salt
oh yeah all that sugar all that good
stuff boil the bottom i'll tell you one
thing
i'll tell you one thing chicago may be
dirty but some of the best food you will
ever eat chicago you know you know that
i i grew up in chicago and i tell you
they're culturally lacking in a lot of
ways you want to be big in music
you can't be in chicago there's no scene
you want to be a skateboarder there's no
scene
you want to be in any kind of sports
there's no scene but if you want to make
good food chicago is the place
because we have the taste of chicago on
the fourth third and fourth of july
and chicago's got food man for days what
is the scene in chicago politics
food it was like a it was a lot of
business it felt like there was a good
thing there's nothing there's nothing
it's a big city full of nothing it's
like a knockoff new york city
it is it's i know but like new york
actually has stuff
had well i call it
i used to say chicago is the suburb city
of the major cities
where it's like when you live in the big
city you're there it's hip there's clubs
you see all the celebrities
when you got the suburbs it's like these
little smaller clubs and people are like
trying to emulate what the cities are
like
chicago is like that all right there are
bands in chicago nobody will ever heard
of that are the biggest bands in the
world to chicagoans
okay so i all right there's a question i
guess for all of you then
what city has it now well
i don't know man it l.a probably i don't
know what's dying it sounds like but
what city
l.a i mean remove it from it remove
covet
l.a dude it's hot it's hot yeah i mean
before covered it was new york for sure
yeah so are you saying that like new
york had it because
and then cobra wrecked it all uh i think
bloomberg and giuliani ruined it all
slo-mo
yeah what about de blasio
you know finisher on there but i'm
thinking about it i'm thinking about
outside of the united states i'm
thinking about places
like uh puerto vallarta i'm thinking
about places like porto
uh i i'm not thinking about anything in
the united states but but comparatively
if i'm had to choose somewhere in the
united states i would have to pick
uh let's just say somewhere in florida
austin maybe uh
texas austin is is is a big kind well
they got elon
they got yeah but they got because now
people are flocking to austin
because of all these other places being
bad you're going to start seeing a
you know it's a big cultural hub now
with a lot of people denver has that too
uh is it crowder close to austin i don't
know
he's in texas yeah i know that it's
obviously the the
part of the what collects it everyone a
lot of them have been
floating over to denver too yeah yeah
yep
yeah well how about we take super chats
from the crowd if you haven't already
smash the like button send in your super
chats when i start reading your comments
don't forget to like subscribe share hit
the notification button go to
timcast.com become a member
to tune in to our members only post
which come up just after the show
but let's read what what's going on here
in this year uh super chat
so let's see here i can't read the name
of this person because youtube has done
this weird thing
that has blocked whatever okay let's see
we got here curtis
maver says tim did you hear about the
water treatment plant that got hacked in
florida on friday
kind of runs into the story from 4 p.m
yeah did you guys hear about this
water treatment plant got hacked they
tried they tried poisoning the water
supply
yeah yeah man who tried to be stuff i
don't know i don't know but i got
arrested i heard but i haven't read into
it yeah
crazy where was this again florida wow
tweed music says hi tim and crew a huge
fan of the work you guys do
and i loved what you did in sweden back
in the day hold the line through an
email if you ever need an insider in
scandinavia appreciate it
pirate tomsky says if france can stand
up to this then the uk
then the uk too next usa critical race
theory woke is definitely hate speech
against groups of people
identity is key apparently the far left
will eat itself p.s
luke is awesome you know i'll tell you
i'll tell you
i agree it is it is uh
they say they're all about diversity
equity and inclusion
and that is the easiest way to debunk
that is they will not
include trump supporters right it's just
plain and simple
yeah so who are they inclusive towards
right not everybody
china that's the commission
it's not inclusive at all because they
literally exclude lots of people it's
always been about
ethnic religious and racial diversity
so long as the mental
state and line of thinking is the same
yeah
so crazy it's wild i keep thinking about
the puritanism
i wonder if it's like modern puritanism
rather than calling it woke i'm just
gonna call it pure
puritanic yeah see if they'll stop doing
it
yeah no i totally i mean like it is in a
in
a
large in a significant way about
purifying
people's thoughts i mean that the
the people have entertained re-education
camps here in the united states the
truth and reconciliation committees
simply because
and covet camps and kobe camps simply
because they want to make sure those
people
disengage from the wrong thing yep
purifying mind about so we got uh
gareth green says swaraj means honorable
king
actually it means light but if you uh if
you're a
it's a it means light in arabic but if
you're a friend of mine and you like to
rip on me
it means lamp lamp
not like a genie lamp like an actual
like house appliance well he says
sriraj oh no it's s-i-r-a-j no no but
is he saying does sriracha mean honor
booking a different word
probably definitely i mean not
on the internet uh just call me lamp
there you go lamp uh
vexel says luke is there any way you
could ask youtube to stop shadow banning
your channel
also do you make your own crystal wraps
or do you have a good vendor i was
actually thinking about making my own
crystals because i sell a whole bunch of
stuff i saw like custom probiotics and
vpns all the
wild stuff but uh i'm gonna get on that
and uh yes
youtube uh please stop sharing me please
uh
bring me back into the department
whatever it's okay um
it's fine but i thank you for your
consideration and thanks for thinking
about me
look you went after eric schmidt so
they're like they're laughing they're
laughing right now the google hq
like it's never gonna end yeah yeah so i
understand it's cool
i'll just keep pedaling t-shirts it's
fine you ever grow your own crystals
uh no no but uh that's something
interesting that i that we might
get into oh i'm into it let's do it all
right emperor guy cerrick says america
has gotten so proficient at destroying
other countries
we don't even have to drop bombs or
provide freedom fighters with weapons
anymore
yeah there you go france is going down
gareth green says some kinds of feminism
say that only men should wash dishes
i would like to protest uh protest that
religion is not a matter of blind faith
or subjective emotion by the way
interesting d-e-m-p-o-l
says look up where during the french
revolution they put up they put a hooker
on the altar
and said we now worship the goddess of
reason chickens come home to roost
they really do that that was a mess i'd
believe it
really no freedom thoughts as a sale on
french rifles
never fi never fired and only dropped
once
[Laughter]
cheers from missouri also missouri just
passed a bill that bans all federal gun
laws
really i gotta look into missouri that's
crazy
yeah did they do that because that means
you could have full auto right you could
build st
louis no missouri yeah but missouri just
passed a bill missouri i wonder if that
means
in the city of salem maybe it's like
city by city now well they probably got
city ordinances
interesting but does that mean that the
constitution no longer protects
well the federal government will
probably come in anyway because that's
what they did to california with
marijuana so
we'll see geffdaff says got my i am a
gorilla shirt saturday
i had ordered it tuesday two days before
the misprint announcement but no luck
got a normal one
still love it but when is the tin foil
one for members only coming
we have to find a vendor that we can put
up on the site
so but we might put up the it's the the
tin foil head one was meant to just go
for about one week
so we'll get it soon i could probably
just put it up um
i don't know maybe thursday is it the
day because it never gets paid friday or
whatever then you have a week
and then we'll put up for just over a
week then take it out like the following
monday so everyone has a chance to get
the special tinfoil head edition
all right let's see brandon r says
re-french surrender jokes
i used to agree but listen to dan
carlin's world war one podcast
miniseries blueprint for armageddon
and see why the french avoid fights i
don't make those jokes very good
podcasts well but mexico what was that i
want to i want to learn
hardcore history what was the episode
blueprint for armageddon
i'm going to listen to that wow so i
think it's fair to point out i think
france has like one of the best war
records of any european nation or like
country in the world for the most part
and it's just because of world war ii we
mock them for surrendering but uh the
the the french empire was massive they
they
look at napoleon surrendered too when
you look at the way they fight
in protest i mean i i have yeah there's
not so many such veracity
such such spirit and fight anywhere to
be honest with you look up verson
generics he fought against julius caesar
and was one of the greatest
unifiers of francia of gaul at the time
and
the romans want to like stamp that guy's
name out because he was such a great
we laugh at the french but they're
fighters they are they are like some of
the most brutal protests you'll ever see
man
gareth green says if someone tried to
plow my driver without asking permission
i'd be angry about them whoever they
were
people who are nice to me against my
will really make me angry
well there you go hunter laces has been
a fan for a while love these daily live
streams
would like to see some 2a related
content or maybe a video of you guys the
range
thanks for everything your guys do well
um maybe
this saturday when we go to the range
maybe we can film it because we filmed a
little bit last time i put some
instagram videos
but maybe we'll actually film some stuff
there's a guy that wants us to ride in
tanks
so uh i gotta email them back that would
be really fun to do but if you guys have
any uh fun uh you know
adventurous things uh definitely email
us let us know i'm down for
weekend adventures yeah i think we
should uh we should film at the range
for real
eve welcome says tim i survived a cult
the behavior of the journalist
isn't cult-like it's straight-up cult
friendship
outside the cult is forbidden i see it
from the left and right and it's
frightening
i i definitely but i don't know if you
guys would agree but it seems like the
rights element of it are
much smaller and more diminished than
the left right like
the left is mainstream media it's
massive cultural institutions and the
right it's like fringe internet
communities
you know what i mean that's for sure
seems like it anyway all right let's see
what we got here
the bros durham says i'm still waiting
on the dopamine payoff from playing
escape from tarkov oh that game's
hardcore
[Laughter]
what is it it's like fps but it's like
super realistic
and you get dropped into this area
called tarkov and you're up against
other players and bots
and you just fight your way to the exit
oh cool you like earn credits
i'm currently working on demon souls the
playstation 5
it's classic isn't it yeah they remade
it yeah oh you should get that for ps5
that is
i think it might be multiplayer i feel
basically actually yeah
i like call of duty and april now call
of duty is great too the
cole i like i play skater xl
okay you guys sure do you were dropping
off the roof yesterday yeah skater xl is
fun so it's a really good skate skate
basically i think i would drop like 40
feet and land and he'd be skating
no no i jumped off a building onto a
handrail that was hilarious
360 flip 50 50 off of like a third
four-story building
all right let's see vp says how many
reza azlan tweets has siraj flagged
a lot probably right reza aslan you know
there have been
i think the last one i did was
uh rbg when he was saying that they were
going to
riot in the streets if they replaced
rbgc or fill the rbgc with
uh amy coney barrett and i was like
that's
i think i think he i think the specific
wording was like that they would burn
the ish down
yes yes that's what i i got him on the
list for that that was the last thing
you know what's funny is like
it's not a it's it's you're just
responding to people like wagging your
finger basically right
yeah well i mean i hit them with the
list meme of course
but what i mean is like their response
should be to like
okay okay and laugh about it oh yeah no
they don't freak out there's some who
handle it really well you know who
actually really
handled it really well aaron rupar from
vox oh really he actually handled it
really well
um what did he say i think he like
you know yeah lmao that kind of thing
but then
he unfollowed me when he was
when i put him on the list after he was
politicizing
congressman-elect luke letlow's death
who died
that's when i lost him
and uh the list also and another guy
who's on twitter max kennerly
he had like a very like ghoulish post
about luke letlow's death and it's just
like come on
guys like it's just unnecessary and
people just tweet because they can't
they don't think beforehand
and they end up beforehand maybe they
just don't think well they don't
yeah they don't think at all but it's
just um
it it gets to the point where i have to
now
not whitewash but like almost sanitize
the list because
it's once something is no longer unique
and becomes a narrative you can't just
go after one particular person you have
to then go after the idea
oh yeah i be profane nope says luke i
got my orwell shirt today love it thank
you guys and girl for the news
nice thanks for wearing it no problemo
jordan d says when are you all going to
do dmt and commune with interdimensional
beings
march ian's planned this one out i'm
ready
let's see brandon hoover says former la
resident now in central pa
i'm happy to have discovered this show
and jimmy dore during covet
it's a thinking person's show and i
listen nightly while i tie
while i talk while time flies i see it
says while i tie flies
i think he's tying flies for fishing
yeah that's what's up oh actually yeah
yeah
that's what you're doing fly fishing huh
cheers to all of you
yeah jimmy's awesome jimmy dore's great
they hate him
because he's a legit he's a real
anti-establishment populist leftist
and that means he calls it out when they
when they play dirty games
he'd be one of those dudes in the 60s
that would have been standing up with a
megaphone in front of crowds at
washington monument like
screaming about like the war and the war
but now it's like the modern version of
that is we have the internet video
yeah uh i haven't i haven't followed
jimmy dore closely but i
know how anti-establishment he is that
just like
his reputation precedes him yeah i think
uh
jimmy's great i think kyle kalinski's
cool dude uh i think
he's pretty rad i like crystal ball
they're you know i think they all
deserve their criticism when they
deserve it i think i do as well
i just my thing is like i don't care
what your political opinions are when it
comes to
you know health care or economics or
policy socialist
capitalist communist so long as you
don't believe in oppressing other people
through violence and coercion and force
and you're honest non-aggression
principle
yeah that's that's that's the gist of it
like i tell the story all the time where
i shook the hand of this communist guy
wearing a sickle and hammer flag
because he denounced antifa straight up
when i asked him i was like these guys
go around
they claim to be either anarchists or
communists and they beat people
and he's like that's wrong they
shouldn't do that and i was like
dude but they say they're communists and
he's like yeah well they have no idea
what they're talking about that's not
the way it's supposed to be and i was
like here brother
i don't care if you're a communist so
long as you agree that we talk things
out we
we don't agree against each other if you
want communism by all means argue all
day and night for it
and if you convince people then my ideas
have lost well that's that's
and that's where that's where things
have changed is that people
it used to be that you try to persuade
others that your ideas are the best
ideas
now it's come to the point where you're
not convincing other people you're
coercing them you're
beating the crap out of them you're you
know you know trashing their entire
store
burning cities to try to prove your
ideas are better than the other side
that's just not how it works no
this guy this guy in berkeley this
comedy guy he was a unicorn it was like
the one time i've ever met
a leftist who was like you shouldn't be
able to use violence against people that
defies the idea of what communism is
supposed to be
the funny thing is he's right if we're
talking about a truly stateless system
where everyone's cooperating and working
together and no one's above anyone else
you shouldn't be able to go around just
beating random people so the people who
do that
do not actually believe in what they
claim to to preach about
they're not talking about some kind of
star trek future they're just talking
about beating you until they have the
power over you
that's not any kind of ideology other
than authoritarianism and you should be
able to communicate with
all ideologies anyone that's like a
communist isn't
doesn't necessarily going to always be a
communist if you have a good
conversation with someone their
political beliefs can change
yeah all right we got brokerages uh no
oh
i'm sorry it says wow brokages over
hokage's you see if i read the last word
i would
have understood that he says hey tim i'm
from san diego from san diego and the
reason i left the republican party
is because they do not represent my
values trump did
very interesting matthew velasquez says
gorilla says fleeing the gop i want by
silver now
image jpeg says i left the gop because
of what they did to trump not a
rejection of trumpism
also bch to the moon book recommendation
on uh book book recommendation the
bitcoin standard
mark jensen says i live in colorado when
the vote to legalize weed was on the
ballot i voted against it
i knew that legalizing it would bring a
bunch of californians here and make our
state even bluer
sure did i mean that's tough man because
i think it should be legal
you know what happened when lydia were
you there when they legalized yeah it
was so i actually voted against it and
one of the things that i noticed was
that
people from california came and a lot of
them when they weren't able to find
these jobs that were actually still
pretty rare
they would become homeless they were
just kind of like vagrants they would
hang around
at least that was my impression because
i would drive past a bunch of them on my
way to work and everything so
oh man we we got a pretty strong rebuke
of you ian okay
should i read it um we're gonna rate it
we're gonna read it written online
yeah here we go drew richmond says ian
needs to play some super mario brothers
mushrooms encourage violence not prevent
it
i think mario was already violent wasn't
he he eats mushrooms punches bricks and
then jumps just makes it more resilient
yeah he can take hits when he's big you
know there's a really there's a really
there's a really funny uh uh web cartoon
of mario eating a mushroom and then like
tripping out and then jumping eternal
and splattering it and like
like just like punching bro you could
punch bricks but once you eat mushrooms
he could smash that
that's true he couldn't break him until
he ate the shrooms that's funny
that game's ridiculous man
the grizzly says you guys going to talk
about the russian convoy that sideswiped
a us vehicle causing injuries
injuries to u.s soldiers it's kind of
exploding all over i didn't hear that
you guys hear that
i heard that a couple months ago but not
now not recently
interesting david merwin says you all
would be awesome higher leadership in
the libertarian party
and be the change that inspires you yeah
the problem is the libertarian party is
too libertarian what if we just started
a party you guys think we could the
pizza party
the pizza party pool party the pool
party
whatever yeah the people parties
targets on us which is annoying like if
we were really
speaking to the world and trying to you
know changing policy
the pool party economy everyone would be
like trying to hack our [ __ ]
our stuff on our phones like we don't
have a
and like looking for every little hole
and constantly harassing us that's the
annoying part like but
if we just build the system that that's
better
then maybe we don't have to be like
targets
i don't know man politics is a dirty
game i don't want to be
you yeah you almost don't i mean i'm
almost always
it's almost never a case where you're
like never a target if you try to start
up a new party
you're a threat to the system you're
you're threatening other people's power
they're going to do everything they can
to make sure you don't get it so
i mean that's why they took that's why
the
that's why the establishment's focus on
trump was so intense is because he
represented this
immense threat to their power and
whether people
liked or hated him you know he
represented something that was much
bigger
and he tried to bring people back to
this idea that
we're a united states of america we're a
sovereign nation we don't sell out to
you know foreign interests like the
chinese communist party
or these international trade deals or or
these international global packs
we decide our future and people just
particularly people who are invested in
those particular
packs or deals they don't want it
vosh had a really funny tweet about
trump earlier he said
why are we wait something like i'll
paraphrase why are we wasting time with
this impeachment just throw trump in
in into a lake and if he sinks he's
guilty we figured this out ages ago
and it was good i left but i responded
if trump floats that means he weighs the
same as a duck
if he weighs the same as the duck it
means he's made of wood and if he's made
of wood he's a witch
you guys get the reference yes
yeah that was an awesome stuff actually
one of them i think it was eric either
blocked me because i put them on the
list
[Laughter]
i'm not even joking about that i love
the
i think it's john kalis where he's like
if you want to be a right-wing extremist
you just got to choose if you want to be
an extremist just choose which groups
you hate then you'll figure out your
left or right
and the funny thing is when he goes to
the list of who the right hates he ends
with and of course
moderates and if you want to be on the
left then he names all the people the
left hates then he goes and of course as
well
moderates like they just hate everybody
all right we got this uh this
massive super chat from lanius shrike
who says people who have never been in a
fist fight before are aggressively
shutting down
open discourse and any chance for
negotiation why
because they don't understand what leads
up to a fight how to avoid a fight
or how to fight a fight they have zero
life experience
they are a sad blend of pompous hubris
naivety and outright insanity
that's a good i absolutely agree good
point the people who have been in fights
are like i don't want to get into a
fight dude
it's funny when you look at wild animals
people are scared of bears and mountain
lions
bro bears and mountain lions know not to
get into a fight it's a huge
risk it's not worth it life is better
than that
you think about i'll tell you a story
man when i was a little kid
there was a i'll have to keep this one
very very vague for potential legal
issues but there was
there was a place where some guys were
working and then an office party
and one of the guys started hitting on
the other guy's wife so
then the dude let's call let's say guy a
is married and guy b is hitting on
guya's wife so guy a starts saying knock
it off
get away from my wife so guy b being a
tough guy
swings at guy you know so guy a i think
you know pushes him gets away from my
wife
guy b escalates the fight punches guy a
in the head
who falls back hits his head on the
table dies instantly
guy b goes to prison over over what yeah
he said some dumb words some lady he
could have just violence is crazy you
know but but
ultimately like the murderer was guy b
went to prison but guy a
didn't need to to push him and then guy
b
escalated it so sometimes you know it
can go back and forth but sometimes the
important thing is just walk away
yeah like get somewhere else if you
fight someone and you both get hurt
who's the victor it doesn't make i mean
i guess there's a time and a place for
combat but
fights does not solve problems for them
sometimes you have to
you know fights happen sometimes there's
a desperate animal right
is it bears and mountain lions might not
want to attack you
if they're starving they will they will
and then you got to fight back you got
to defend yourself
you know so it's it's difficult here but
i guess the idea with that guy was that
he was
picking a fight and provoking by going
after the guy's wife and then he he's
the one who threw the punch
sage meek says tim the gang have you
watched the interview with yuri besmanov
the xkgb agent on the topic of
ideological subversion
what are your thoughts how far along do
you think we are
we have all definitely seen it many many
times and i don't know how far far along
we are maybe we're past the the event
horizon
i keep forgetting to and to ask you
edward griffin to come on he's the guy
who interviewed
uh the kgb agent but uh he was very
telling there's a there's a reason
that video has gone viral so i think
we're in touch with
with edward uh i put you in touch lydia
with his
mail his uh marketing manager or
something very cool yeah we look it up
yeah that'd be interesting but we'll get
into it in greater detail on a later
show i suppose
stormman says tim love the show and luke
and ian are awesome
but did you see that the board of
supervisors of maricopa county may soon
face arrest
as arizona senate fast tracks their
contempt vote
no i didn't see that that's crazy monty
is bad at gaming says let's hear
something less stressful how about that
one division show okay i got a lot i got
a lot to say about one division i
haven't seen that
the first here's my advice to you if you
if you if you haven't seen it
skip episodes one two and three whoa
huge waste of time
has nothing to do with anything my mind
was blown
at how bad the show was wow i watched
the first episode
and i thought it was gonna be a five
minute gag
of them pretending to do a 50 sitcom
it's literally like 40 minutes or
whatever
of a fake 50 sitcom and that's oh okay
maybe that was just the first episode
second episode i was like what is this
third episode i was like are you kidding
me
honestly i didn't watch it i thought you
were saying juan as in the name
juan division huh juan division like
it's like
like mexican enjoyed it's like a mexican
like a
hispanic fbi division yeah i don't know
all right so here's what i want to say
though if you if you want wanda
vision yeah if you want to watch a show
just start from episode four oh vision
that's vision
yes he's got the red face though instead
of those pure silver
white vision what do you mean like in
the comics vision was white for a long
time the first vision was the original
one was red
vision start with episode four and the
show is great
it's fun so in episode four they
basically explain the first three
episodes and why they wasted your time
and i'm like why would they do that
other than they just fill episodes and
claim they have more episodes
so it wasn't like any character
development none episodes are there
different writers
in it i have no idea what if the writer
so it's like fired it's like you watch
the first episode
and it's it's supposed to be a gimmick
of i don't know i'd be which
wasn't bill or something like no it's
like bewitched yeah the writers are
powerful
the show's tanking we got to change the
premise so they started no but they had
this already
yeah yeah the whole season though or
were they writing the whole season
already felt
like it is i'll tell you this whenever
they do
the hokie so so even like episode four
it's the real world now they're
explaining what's going on and it's
really fun show
episode five is a mix i just fast
forward through anything where they're
pretending to do it
i don't normally want you to spoil stuff
but i'm going to ask you later to tell
me more about that my advice to you is
fast forward through it when wanda when
the show is a fake
fake tv show because it's a waste of
your time and then as soon as you see
the real
show with the fbi agents and the sword
agents to actually watch it that's
interesting
yeah so now like tim you've made me want
to watch the first three episodes
because i wanted to no no trust me
no you'll watch five minutes and turn it
off
you really will i think so trust me this
poop is stinky it's stinky
you're not going to want to smell it
people just got up and walked out of the
room they're like what is this
do you do you like the show bewitched i
haven't seen it since i was a kid
but you know what it is right yeah what
the second darin yeah the second
the first airing got fired or something
yeah why you get fired
oh i don't know the history of it anyway
look it's okay bewitched was a fun show
okay but would you would you watch
knockoff bewitched
i just watched bewitch i wouldn't i just
watched bewitch i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna watch this this is stupid but
it's really bad too does he shoot lasers
out of his eye don't spoil it for me
the the actual story is interesting but
they
like dude out of let's see you've got
what like 35 to 40 minutes for each
episode so you got five episodes
out of all of that time there's only
about an
actual 50 minutes of content wow out of
you know three three hours and 20
minutes yeah there's only about 50
minutes it's actual content
the rest is just like you're watching us
imagine if you watched a youtube video
that was spoofing bewitched
on youtube it would be three minutes
long and you'd laugh at the jokes
imagine if they made it for 40 minutes
you'd be like okay dude i get it to
bewitched interesting
anyway is it more than five episodes
right now it's five i think six is
coming out soon
but there there's important mcu
developments happening in the show
oh so i just fast forward through when
they pretend to be a tv show
because it's the stupidest most
mind-numbing garbage
i have ever watched but the actual story
is interesting
yeah will billy the hillbilly says to
answer your question why dems are moving
to towns and red areas
city slickers want to to move live
country and rustic
but don't want to live far from stores
restaurants and repairmen
they don't want the responsibility of
living in the real country that's true
chopping wood and starting fires now
they need the internet
right all right let's see we had a big
job we'll take uh
we'll take a few more of these here we
got silently in atlanta says
georgia underestimated impact of
becoming the hollywood of the south
many brought their blue view with them
ossoff commercials touted him as a
filmmaker with dr wife
reduced tax breaks new saiyan tmt tom
mcdonald topic
is that what because you want tom uh
mcdonald on the show yeah
that'd be funny he's cool dude georgia
yeah someday
paul balak says doubling down on my last
super chat free apparel pitch for we are
change.org
one face mask with print of dog muzzle
two face mask made to look like a bra
with the phrase free the lip
ah we do have some face masks the dog
muzzle one is good
let's say uh and one has a picture of
the mpc lips
one says censored uh we have a whole
bunch of different ones available for
you guys
abex eckstein says hey siraj it's weird
watching you without yasher taking over
the chat
why does he do that because i'm my
habibi bros the bb power hour that's uh
10 p.m
on wednesday nights on youtube uh
yeah sure pops yeah pops in and and
trolls me and jet
he's a cool dude yeah people seem to
really like that guy really like ishar
he's he's a connected dude he knows uh
he knows a lot of people
is that he's a co-host no no he's a
journalist but he's one of the few
journalists where conservatives and
liberals are like
they think he's alright oh cool maybe we
can on the show someday he's all the way
out in cali
yeah i mean we fly people out yeah okay
all right here we go trey
evans has been watching your show for
years now time i pay for this free
content keep it the good work hey really
appreciate it
but the better thing you can do is go to
timcast.com and become a member
that way if we ever get banned we have a
place where our content will exist
and we're producing exclusive podcast
segments and episodes for members only
so
that does remind me you can pay 4.99 a
month to this channel on youtube to
become like a channel member that gives
you like special color emotes in the
chat but it doesn't
doesn't give you any website so just
probably you haven't done this but just
in case make sure if you subscribed on
youtube
that's not the website they're different
yeah timcast.com i think that's what
people are confused
about all right let's see we got here
gizzy mack says there's an oil spill in
the bay area there was a
there was a five gallon leak every
minute can't check more on it at work
interesting we'll look into that
kristen larsen ian did you have any luck
in love or did you fail
i had much luck in love actually i was
uh
i spent like seven years with one girl
and um
then i was single for a while then did
another girl for four years and uh i i
toyed with
with with roping in and like settling
down and i don't know
i kind of sometimes i have regrets but i
try to live without them like
part of me is like i should have just
married her man and had had the kids and
lived that life because she'd just be
here with me right now
but maybe i wouldn't be here right now
if i did do that you're gonna get
you're gonna get visited by um what's
the guy's name marley
yeah he's gonna be like look at what you
meant
it's your old business partner video
games from your head shop this is not
falling off
where did you put the blunt aren't you
here to tell me
yeah aren't you here to tell me about
fixing my life what no i just can't find
the wii
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's stoned he's like sitting in the
room and you're like you have a message
what
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out we do the show live monday the
friday at 8 pm we will be back tomorrow
night of course
you can follow me on twitter instagram
and mines at timcast my other youtube
channels are youtube.comcast
youtube.comcastnews don't forget to like
share
subscribe to this channel if you're
listening on the podcast leave us a good
review it really really does help
go to timcast.com we will have a bonus
segment for you coming up in just a
moment later tonight
after we record it and uh sorry you want
to mention your your social media
anything like that
yeah you can find me on twitter i'm at
siraj a hash me if you can spell it
there you go i couldn't three times
it's just look up s-i-r-a-j that's me on
twitter
of course you can find us on youtube by
finding obviously that name as well
um and then uh if you want to check out
the list i'm on patreon
um siraj hashmi is the name again
let's just look up the look up the the
name on twitter
all of it is in the bio you don't have
to worry boom there you go
i personally am taking full advantage of
the 24 hour delete feature on instagram
and
if you want to see my questionable
content you can on luke we are change
also the shirt i'm wearing right now uh
i made after i was inspired by the
gamestop uh rebellion well let's let me
read it and it says
banker noun ruthless scumbag who will
eat your lunch and then charge you for
it
yes and if you wish to get this shirt
you can on the bestpoliticalshirts.com
and thank you guys for having me really
appreciate your time here
and you can follow me ian crossland uh
on the internet at twitter where i'm
very proactive and like to interact at
minds which i was a co-founder of you
can
subscribe to me on youtube and uh follow
me on twitch.tv slash ian crosson where
i do daily not daily necessarily streams
but
stream free twists too that's a good
game
what do you what do you play uh right
now i i did say demon soul's a duke odd
um i'm gonna get i'm i just started
ghost of
tsushima i call it ghost of hashima i'm
like my lesson oh that's funny
yeah well hey and do me a favor well do
this for yourself when this ends leave a
comment
when the stream's over go down there and
leave something funny leave something
interesting
let us know what you're thinking say one
good thing about antifa
[Laughter]
be positive that's right everybody
should say one good thing about the
person is that's like a therapy thing
right i like how they dress
stylish hoodies yeah they they knew
kovit was having them before everyone
else
all right trendsetters all right
oh yeah and me sour patch lids i'm on
twitter at
sour patch lids i'm on mines at
sourpatch liz i'm on instagram and
gab at real sour patch lids it is a
little different
other people stole my username so weak
yeah i know
thank you all so much for hanging out we
will have a bonus segment for you coming
up at timcast.com members only sign up
and we will see you all then
you